ok tu te bats en place terry je suis en
place
surtout fait une entrée je fais pas ce
soir tu la fais pas non un bon d'accord
donc je fasse une entrée
ok ok ok je suis entrée au quai
au milieu d'hommes en noir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avec les uns soir eddy mitchell
une scop com
hassine doghri gens courent
les weeks as
jean luc reichmann
jean pierre castaldi
guillaume coche
coscia
on négocie
alors on habite
[Musique]
et
voici eddy mitchell
oui
alors j'ai dit 'je est pas venu pour
rien tiens un livre un album illustré de
200 photos un texte de sam bernett qui
raconte votre vie du rockeur aux
couleurs voilà alors c'est un livre très
intéressant c'est moi ce que j'aime en
fait dans les bio des stars c'est
l'enfance voilà alors naissance en 42 du
côté de la place des fêtes dans le 19e
arrondissement
vos parents s'appelle lucienne et robert
c'est nerveux
non mais ça fait un peu film de lelouch
kuzeo missionnaire aubergine et et
marcel et oui je sais c'est un peu ça la
soeur s'appelle gisèle et le frère
s'appelle tiers vous vous êtes le petit
dernière le petit gars t'es des clones
un oui le petit chouchou quoi ni un
petit chouchou de la paix - oui mais
alors vous voulez pas sur l'or dans
cette famille le soir pour dîner vous
dites en ont mais un morceau de pain
dans un bol de vin rouge quoi c'est
quand même pas souhaiter ça à ça c'est
l'été à l'hiver c'est quoi une bonne
grosse soupe non oui et puis la fin du
mois se termine le 15 h y allait d'un
coup
votre père héros discret de la
résistance mais qui se retrouve comme à
bosser à la ratp quoi comme votre père
travaille la nuit le jour il a le temps
de s'occuper de vous il vous amène voir
des western des thrillers des péplums
dans les cinémas de quartier il vous
amène voir des combats de catch et c'est
lui finalement kivu forme complètement
ah oui donc totalement et puis même au
niveau
au niveau littérature puisque mon pote
est très très très ouvert lyzel de tous
allaient de aussi bien de puisqu'à
l'époque
la grande star du polar c'était plus
tard chez nous aussi bien de plus tard
chez mais en passant par sartre faille
tout manger donc vous lisiez les livres
de peter chan et vous allez voir la môme
vert de gris avec un ris constantine
ouais c'est toute une culture c'est vrai
bah oui oui c'est vrai oui c'est
important c'est bien mais alors vous
n'avez pas beaucoup aux lycéens faut
bien le dire non à vous préférez draguer
fumée glandais 1 c'est plutôt ça votre
sur vous ajoute c'est quand même plus
alors dans la famille des dix mises à
part votre père qui travaille la ratp la
nuit tout le monde travaille au crédit
lyonnais donc vous vous retrouvez est
coursier à lagence richelieu drouot
bientôt vous êtes viré parce qu'en tant
que course évidemment vous barrez sur
leur petite mobylette et vous avez tout
faire sauf sauf du travail et et
finalement vous êtes viré mais cette
expérience vous permet de découvrir ce
qu'on appelle le triangle d'or c'est à
dire entre les grands boulevards le
square de la trinité la rue richelieu et
là vous rencontrer deux autres glandeurs
passionné de rock qui sont johnny
hallyday est rond et jacques dutronc est
ce que je trouve assez extraordinaire
quand même c'est si cette rencontre quoi
les trois plus grands jouer ensemble à
l'adolescence c'est très bizarre quand
même mais c'est le hasard oui mais c'est
un hasard extraordinaire sera
merveilleux skis et de surtout de
merveilleux c'est qu'on soit resté non
seulement en très bons termes mais qu'on
soit vraiment des amis ne proposait pas
rencontré dick rivers c'est marrant la
vie
si le tennis si je connais bien c'est ça
et lui il était né soir et alors bientôt
vous découvrez le golf drouot qui
deviendra le berceau du rock français
nous quand on l'a inconnu c'était un
endroit pour vieille dame qui me prendre
le thé café l'anglais derek au dessus du
café d'angleterre c'était vraiment un
minigolf un golf miniature donc que 401
true north et rien derrière ouais ouais
alors ce qui est drôle c'est votre
première rencontre ça je savais pas avec
jean philippe smet donc futur johnny
hallyday il vous piquent des disques
mais c'est vrai nom mais ne à-côtés pas
très loin de 8 avec des martyrs est une
une surprise party comme l'ont dit et
dont j'avais amené des lices comme tous
les gamins comme tout qu'on ne nous
étions et en partant quand ça se termine
faut les rares embarqués et les miens je
les trouvais pas il y avait mon cas ma
johnny qui lui les avait confiés au
concierge
en disant je repasserai répondre plus
tard voilà et a voulu coller au mur
peint vous récupérez vos disques
attendait c'était les premiers 45 tours
jean vincent sasso vue donc entre johnny
et vous ça a commencé par un parent à
baston au baston bobo bien méchant
besoin de gameplay pourquoi tu aimes ça
bah parce que j'aime ça et d'un seul
coup on a parlé de choses beaucoup plus
importantes que dutronc qui à l'époque
était un vrai dandy
chapeau enfoncé jusqu'aux oreilles
imperméable cintrée à la taille oui
c'est vrai qu'il avait un côté on
l'appelait liasse tonderai car il se
tenait exprès pour pour le gag se tenait
toujours beauté avec un imperméable et à
l'époque il avait des foyers triple
triple désert triple foyer comme ça et
quand il draguait on appelait ça
l'opération j table
c'était avant sa métamorphose parce
qu'après lui après c'est devenu le
playboy que
qu'il est toujours de lancer l'époque
vous récoltez le surnom de schmoll
une fille qui s'appelait la valise parce
qu'elle avait un des envies les normes
paraît-il beaucoup n'ont pas franchement
non elle avait une intelligence très
proche de d'un maillage est d'ailleurs
le truc drôle c'est que je les croisais
il ya peu de temps à antalya il analyse
valérie labbé wade les croisés à saint
tropez je l'envoie si elle est excellent
le son poste et j'ai même pas eu le
temps de dire bonjour la valise conserva
pick up est parti
alors à l'époque vous formez votre
premier groupe qui s'appelle les five
rocks 1 mais quand il ya le premier
passage sur europe 1 vous découvrez vous
appelez les chaussettes noires parce
qu'elle avait un deal entre votre maison
de disques à un marchand de chaussettes
télé chaussée le stand ouais mais bon
j'ai appris par la radio j'appelais les
chaussettes noires franchement ça vous a
fait quoi se faisait humilier tous
appelé le show c'est moi
c'était un peu dur quand même c'était
même pas humiliation c'était
consternation dans le jeu on s'est tous
ept est pas important parce que on
pensait qu'on allait faire un effet un
disque on se c'était amusant et puis non
45 ans la tap et c'est vrai mais c'est
vrai non musulmans aujourd'hui c'est pas
toi
dans tous les cas le succès est immédiat
vous avez du succès tout de suite avec
tu parles trop bebopalula daniela et
vous vendez en deux ans deux millions de
dirhams sable à l'époque c'était c'était
énorme
baveux et bien sûr
non mais bon vous prenez ça comme ça
mais c'est quand même extraordinaire oui
mais pas contre ce normal ouais non plus
le truc drôle c'est que c'est vrai ah
bon ben c'est bien c'est formidable puis
on n'avait pas enfin on s'entendait pas
bien compte
le problème c'est que vous partez à
l'armée et d'eads dont on fait trop de
faire comme si on n'a pas le temps à
prendre d'accord afin de tordre à soyez
soyez tranquilles sur 24 heures du mans
à un moment il faut qu'on leur rende
mode zen quand même assez d'accord
voilà alors après vous faites quelques
succès il ya toujours un coin qui me
rappelle s'il n'en reste qu'un alice
enfin début de votre carrière solo dont
il ya quand même une longue traversée du
désert j'ai revu ça en lisant ce bouquin
je me souvenais pas ça va mal hein il ya
une période comme ça qui dure 4 5 ans où
vous êtes quand même culture
quatre ans à la ramasse un gréement
ouais c'est même pas un mot non il
envisage même de reformer le sétois
enfin vous voulez pas un homme / femme
c'était en mai on vous le propose oui
mais seulement s'il vous dire à quel
point ça allait mal oui oui non mais
c'est vrai que je vendais très très peu
de disques e et
et que ce qui faisait peur c'est culés
les anciens discothèque était
reproposer un conflit en se servant des
mieux ouais oui le best-of des
chaussettes noires sans se vendent mieux
que 10 c'est terrible ça ça c'est ce qui
arrive à dave tous les ans vous me direz
un à un ils étaient pas dans les
chaussettes noires le nom
à ce moment là vous faites une émission
plus est une émission de radio qui
s'appelle en attendant que ça se passe
donc c'est bien la preuve vous aviez le
sentiment de même que c'était un moment
qui ne marche pas non plus du barça à
mon
neveu qui marchent pas dans s'était
enfin c'est drôle ce pauvre où c'est
je pense qu'il décrira les qui s'appelle
au fond du trou c'est quelqu'un qui
marche mais ça va pas du tout alors de
kohav vous viviez de quoi à l'époque
j'ai tourné où j'avais pas envie d'aller
d'ailleurs je tournais dans les pays de
l'est roumanie machin tout ça est que le
chou farci tout ce qu'on aime bien et
et je gagnais très bien ma vie mais je
n'étais pas très drôle non et là c'est
le drame non justement alors c'est le
grand retour
c
d'or
non
non mais
c'était là
tél
sap en jeu
où l'eau
fej
[Musique]
tu vois
plus
[Musique]
emportés
demain
[Musique]
euros
avec satellite en pl
bonne idée
comme si le talent
ouais di michele
sédation sont extrait du cd le frenchie
tort comme ça c'est des trucs que vous
avez chanté il ya
un enfant jacques exactement frais
chanson ça non non non il ya d'une
nouvelle enfin quand même si des
interprétations d'aujourd'hui
voilà c'est logique mais j'aime bien
c'est bien
c'est incroyable quarante ans après
avoir commencé vous êtes toujours la
vraie la pêche les lélés les gens vous a
plein de lèche la banane un nom mais
c'est bien bon je suis ravie seriez cru
à cinq essais les durées bien entendre
non mais même de faim je reconnais que
je suis par ninon dans ce cas je pensais
c'est merci merci tous les jours ouais
c'est rien et à mi-parcours ça va durer
encore
jeanne calment du rock avoir n'a pas
fini d'en bouffer
auj
je
sais
man
eddy mitchell
je sens une pour ceux qui ont les blues
alors ai dit vous êtes
vous êtes un rocker maintenant je sais
pas si c'est une rock star on va faire
un test le rockstar test
[Musique]
est ce que vous êtes né dans la rue
je peux enfin je sais pas j'ai pas de
souvenir cet âge là en dessous d'un très
bien est ce que vous êtes déjà battu
pendant un nouveau concert battue ouais
ah oui arrive c'était quand
c'était en corse à bastia il est même
coup de la tête personnage est offert
non c'est vrai
ce qui avait posé son sac
bien qu'on soit là avec nous ça ferait
avec l'organisateur vous venez pas
ventilé la boîte association avec les
pieds dedans non ils voulaient pas me
donner au sol aux autres bref on disait
que bahia do chantait sans micro qui
avait pas de raison ouais donc je mets
un point noir est ce que vous avez déjà
couché avec votre cousine non jamais non
non non
oui mais j'avais je joue pas de piano
non plus loin c'est vrai est ce que vous
êtes déjà mort dans un accident d'avion
non s'il rappelle toi la réponse est non
c'est sympa ça je le prends en 2g bon
est-ce que vous avez déjà saccagé une
chambre d'hôtel oui oui c'est vrai il a
pissé à côté une fois est-ce que vous
avez déjà fait une overdose au palace
non non vous a déjà chanté du charles
trenet oui quoi tu reste-t-il de nos
amours la mer entre autres est-ce que
vous avez déjà chanté avec maurice
chevalier ouais c'est mauvais ça pour
être rockstar ah bon ouais mais lui il a
coulé on n'entend plus parler
fait du bien le twist du canotier est-ce
que vous avez déjà été inquiété pour des
problèmes de drogue dans un aéroport
américain
je suis mauvais vous n'êtes pas mauvais
vous n'êtes pas est un rockeur est pas
une rock star ah bon vous avez déjà
demandé obispo de pas vous composer des
chansons
ça c'est fait c'est pas un peu est-ce
que vous avez quelque chose en nous de
tennessee regarde regarde bien
non mais enfin ça c'est pareil quand on
l'a quand on connaît les tendances
sexuelles de tennessee williams joue
mieux pas d'accord bonne réponse vous
êtes j'ai été agressé par un fan
honnêtement pas non pas comme lennon
quoi au nom
encore un dont on n'entend plus parler
dit elle c'est parce qu'il faut
j'ai déjà allé sur le plateau de la star
academy pour faire de la promo oui deux
fois oui
non moi moi je vérifie un non mais
attendez ça paye mieux qui suit 1
bien on y va et d
excuse a été de boire ou de fumer non
plus ça c'est bien maintenant aller pour
être star c'est bien ah bon oui les
excès il faut faire beaucoup d'excès à
bout j'ai mangé beaucoup de boulot
vous vous jetez dans votre public à la
fin d'un concert en garde
c'est kristin scott thomas
non
vous êtes
vous êtes à la télévision en voit
rarement sur les plateaux de télévision
on est donc d'autant plus content et
flatté que vous soyez là christine voilà
merci je sais que vous n'aimez pas les
gens qui sont impressionnés par vous
vous dites ça me met mal à l'aise alors
je vais essayer de ne pas être trop
impressionné par vous tentez moi les
gens mal à l'aise ça m'impressionne pas
alors en fait je crois vous n'êtes pas
du tout consciente de l'effet que vous
produisez vous dites les gens fantasment
à cause de mes rôles il imagine que j'ai
une espèce de pouvoir de séduction c'est
archi faux
mais je ne peux pas un labour aimé le
jeu oui oui oui oui
c'est pas que cette très jolie très
sensibles à ces s'arrête et chiant c'est
très sympathique merci entre elles ou en
fait alors en fait christine se trouve
pas belle mais si elle le dit elle a
peur de passer pour quelqu'un qui aurait
de la fausse modestie que c'est très
compliqué mais c'est vous que moi ah bon
en tout cas ça vous rend encore plus
attachantes et plus belle
alors vous éclaire dans le terreau d'une
famille très chic aussi tout bon comme
il faut quand même famille commun c'est
une femme est anormal mais pas chic
ouais comme il faut je sais pas
mais comme ils font comme il nous
fallait en tout cas il fallait
alors votre vie ça commence comme un
roman votre père était pilote de chasse
il est mort quand vous aviez cinq ans
votre mère se remarie avec un autre
pilote de chasse qui meurent six ans
après c'est incroyable non oui mais vrai
mais vrai c'est le même incroyable et
est restée
est très difficile pour elle et pour
nous les enfants c'était très difficile
enfin ça c'est des choses qu'on qui nous
fabriquent en face des expériences comme
ça c'est des choses qui qui nous donne
le caractère donc faut pas pleurer je
suis réussi vous avez commencé la
comédie très tôt à l'âge de 4 ans vous
juillet un berger était aussi un berger
un vieux berger en effet avec une canne
c'est pas un peu tard quatre ans pour
jouer un vieillard
mais alors très vite vous êtes aperçu
que c'était là que vous étiez bien quoi
c'était quand vous étiez en
représentation j'aimais beaucoup me
déguiser faire semblant d'être quelqu'un
d'autre et je continue
mais ce soir vous fait l'actrice qui a
fait un film avec régis wargnier vous le
faites très bien d'ailleurs merci alors
votre famille vous décourage de faire de
la comédie parce que par sens des
convenances se faisait pas et vous
décidez de devenir professeur d'art
dramatique ce qu'était une sans doute
une idée wayne fatale
oui j'ai enfin je me suis inscrit dans
une classe où on apprenait être
professeur et je me suis vite aperçu que
c'était vraiment pas la bonne voie et
que pour faire ce que je voulais faire
il fallait que je quitte l'angleterre et
que je recommence à nouveau quelques
braillards et voilà et c'est là que la
france ait hérité de kristin scott
thomas vous deviez 19 ans vous êtes
venus ici comme jeune fille au pair dans
une famille et c'est cette famille qui
vous encourager à faire le métier
d'actrice comme un encouragés à faire ce
que je voulais faire
et c'était à coup c'est d'ailleurs et je
me souviens très bien j'avais tellement
peur d'aller au à la au concours de la
rue blanche que qu'elle m'a mis elle
même
et donc j'ai jamais reparti de france
mais ma maison chez moi c'est si oui
vous dire que vous avez rencontré un
français ça c'est fatal aussi à l'époque
à l'époque il était étudiant en médecine
oui enfin ça c'est la vie privée on va
pas trop en parler mais c'était
aujourd'hui un grand médecin quelle
spécialité faut laisser les cci les
obstétriciens là j'arrive pas à le dire
tu as je préfère ce soir christine qu'il
pilote sébastien jorry pales de
pharmacie homme strict je sais pas
laisser des mots moi il ya des mots que
je sais pas dire sans exemple bateau non
mais attends
c'est pas un mot facile facile ces trois
grands enfants 1 et alors à cause d'eux
à cause de ses enfants donc vous n'avez
pas fait de carrière hollywood c'est
parce que j'ai choisi de privilégier la
vie française la vie que je pouvais
trouver ici avec ma famille mes enfants
plutôt que cavaler la bae
à voir à faire des choses
qui m'attirait plus tellement en fait je
suis allé je suis j'ai fait un tour et
puis je suis revenu vous regrettez pas
jamais si parfois quand les ans à des
pleurs
si parfois on se dit oh j'aurais dû
rester et puis on a plus de liberté et
c'est bizarrement mais le mot nage dans
le cinéma américain c'est très très très
difficile
et là vous voyez les rôles que je viens
de jouer là uniquement en france avec
arsène lupin et puis man to man et
petites coupures
c'est faux c'est fantastique c'est
fabuleux c'est fait les méchantes et en
ce moment un oui j'ai eu une période
méchante c'est fini la bon je suis
plutôt dans les comédies kalmin d'accord
alors en préparant cette interview je me
suis rendu compte que c'est pas la
première fois que vous jouiez avec il
des pygmées
en 86 effet under the cherry moon avec
print
santé laval santé la santé cette santé
l'absolu mais ce film-là ndar dutch high
moon vous l'avez pas mis dans votre
filmographie un aussi bon elle doit
l'être ouais c'est pas du pij de vaches
mères non annonce à faire de ce si c'est
si je suis très fier de ce film c'était
mon premier film je jouais au théâtre
dans un champ en bourgogne une caisse de
magrie brasse et tout d'un coup on
m'appelle pour me demander d'aller faire
des essais avec trinh ce qui était à
l'époque le normand oui non mr et puis
je me suis trouvé dans une limousine en
allant à nice je n'avais jamais essayé
dans un hôtel de mamie un musical a
hélas c'était les hôtels 4 étoiles
c'était mignon bon arrêtez vous je vais
craquer alors vous êtes sans doute
l'anglais ce qu'il connaît le mieux les
français je crois qu'on est plusieurs à
connaître et jane birkin et vous
sarlat
alors affaire à french quiz
[Musique]
alors christine est ce que le français
fait tout le temps la gueule oui
et encore maintenant qu'elle ne prend
pas le métro oui
est ce que le français a vraiment une
hygiène douteuse
peut-être que non à
est-ce que le français se croient
vraiment supérieur aux autres non géré
même contraire à bon avant goût vous
pensez que les fonctions d'un petit
complexe d'infériorité oui oui vous dit
on sur la wii parce que je me sens je me
sens quand même un d'opter et je me suis
adapté
ohlala
vous parlez beaucoup mieux le français
que j'aime bien qu est ce que le
français vraiment nuls en langues
étrangères
pas insinue que les anglais les
américains
est ce que le français est vraiment prêt
à dénoncer son voisin si on le lui
demande oui à est ce que le français est
un mec vraiment les touristes quand ils
viennent en france ah ça je sais pas
parce que jamais ces touristes en
battant kit est vendu ce motorola
[Applaudissements]
est ce que le français dragueur
j'ai du mal à repérer les
mêmes pendant l'acte
était en train de me draguer
pas du tout
est ce que le français passe vraiment
son temps à parler de sexe
non est ce que le français embrasse bien
est-ce que le français fait bien l'amour
est ce que le français sympathique
n'en demandent pas trop tirer
mais si gezin deviers joncour
magnifique christine deviers-joncour
c'est du coin ça du lapin ah le pauvre
et comment ça va eh ben ça va pas mal
christine deviers-joncour dont on vous a
connu [ __ ] de la république est les
saillies on vous a connu chanteuse et
maintenant vous êtes écrivain non mais
je crie 85e oui mais la suite à nantes
on essaie de sa romance
c'est un roman les autres c'était pour
les affaires au moins un outil complet
pour me défendre une battre là on
souffle on parle d'autre chose
qu on parle de cul de la vraie vie oui
christine vous êtes une vraie touche à
tout oui oui
bien alors ensuite christine on vous a
connu chanteuse et là on a découvert
avec stupeur au moment de la sortie du
disque que toute votre enfance biais
travailler le piano avec un grand
musicien espagnol qui avait fui le
franquisme qui s'était réfugié à sarlat
et que normalement vous auriez dû être
christine deviers-joncour chef
d'orchestre compositeur et voilà comme
bien fini sa carrière elle a toujours
mené les hommes à la baguette de tout
au pc je luis la jebba qui a mené la
vie
vient à la baguette c'est dur de
commencer à 55 ans pour une jeune
chanteuse pourquoi vous dites mon âge
moi je dis le mien on a nagé 7,9 des
poils blancs ce n'est pas de la paupière
[Applaudissements]
vous pensez quoi vous pensez quoi
sérieusement festive et pensez quoi de
ces nouveaux chanteurs qui ne savent pas
chanter qui vendent des millions
d'albums alors que vous en vendez
beaucoup moins que savait pas chanter en
plus je
sais pas je ne sais pas chanter je crois
que d'abord j'ai eu envie de décrire
c'est une sage m'exprimer c'est ce qui
m'a motivé en même temps la musique j'ai
toujours baigné est bon si ça marche ça
marche moi je me fais plaisir c'est le
principal ne croyez pas vous auriez dû
chanter pour ceux qui sont loin de chez
eux qu'ils ont dans les yeux quelque
chose qui fait mal
cherchez vous regrettez pas avoir écrit
vos chansons vous même mais je les écris
moi même ça tu regrettes pas
t'as pas écouté l'album si je vais dire
après que je vais coûtent deux fois pas
mais non il est pas sorti
mahfouz
bien j'ai un secret je les écoute à la
bonne vitesse et on recommence
alors donc un [ __ ] de la république
deux chanteuses trois écrivains
un livre après un disque voulait
vraiment on est en prison christine
non parce que là je risquais rien parce
que là on parle pas d'affaires des
quatre rapport à votre place si vous
auriez pas mieux fait de sortir une
ligne de chaussures non
ça ne m'intéresse pas là vous êtes plus
sociaux a dit alors le livre s'appelle
comme le disent que toi masculin mon
féminin c'est aux éditions du rocher et
c'est ennuyant et roddick alors vous
dites j'ai écrit ce livre pour ne pas
mourir au lendemain du procès en appel
après la relaxe du mains en voyant que
je prenais encore les coûts c'est vrai
que j'ai passé quelques mois très durs
j'avais plus tellement de death d'avenir
comme dans sex ouvert ce membre tuméfié
semble prendre naissance et voilages et
nagl bravo
alors c'est l'histoire d'une femme à la
dérive qui vit encore dans le souvenir
du grand amour de sa vie
le grand amour de sa vie c'est un homme
plus âgé qui l'a marqué à jamais mais
qu'il l'a jamais épousé et qui est mort
roland dumas est mort
non c'est pas je vais pêcher donc je
peux pas caché qu effectivement
l'héroïne je me suis complètement geek
aimerait bien sûr parce que j'avais
aussi à travers à travers celle j'avais
besoin de lire des choses donc
effectivement et aussi peut-être j'ai
voulu montrer une femme une femme qui
s'est battu et a pris des sacré coup
dans la gueule et cette femme se
retrouve dans
ce grand amour d'encre acariens avec cet
homme elle n'a plus rien n'est
complètement algérie et elle retombe
amoureuse voilà alors demain qui au
départ est très macho et on découvre
rapidement que c'est une folle tordue en
belgique ont maintenant exiger la clé
il adore se travestir
c'est un jeu c'est certain on a tous en
nous du masculin du fidjien tout le
monde moi j'ai peut-être ces féministes
je crois que j'ai beaucoup de masculin
en moi et je me suis dit en écrivant ce
que j'avais besoin de vivre une histoire
d'amour que je vis pas c'est vrai un peu
seul depuis sept ans et je me suis
immergé là dedans et je me suis dit
voyons quel est le genre d'homme qui
pourrait me faire me faire peut-être
attendre été
imaginé un homme antoine inverse de moi
c'est à dire à la fois masculins et
féminins jouer je
pressentais que c'est son plus haut fait
vrai chat peut tomber dans le 9 3 c'est
quoi le 9 3 ah oui et banlieues 9,3
non je suis pas allé mais on change rien
je connais personne dans ma visite tu
veux connaître du monde très bien et bon
vent et nous donnera une autre miss
russie une page 24 donc c'est un soir
glace et de pleine lune donc oui vous
êtes vous êtes avec le vieux aussi avant
j'étais
alors elle se déshabille derrière un
fourré fait très froid et fait fonction
de ta phrase que je venais à lui dévêtue
et voilà et alors je ne craignais plus
ce froid de mort qui trahissaient comme
une douleur j'avançais encore j'imagine
et le spectacle qui s'offrait à lui je
jubile et à un mètre de lui je
m'arrêtais il s'approcha haute à sa
vareuse qu'il posa à même le sol sur
l'herbe givray ces imams 1 et l'invita
et m'invite à m'allonger j'obéis son
corps recouvrit sans aucun préliminaire
il écarta mais en tout cas c'est bien
conjuguer parce que vers
d'autres gares il écarte une maison ce
qui ne voulait rien dire les cartes à ce
mes jambes tout est bien conjuguer en
tout cas dans la ceinture brutale comme
un viol je senti ça que red me pénétrer
écarter les chères comme une déchirure
son désir était violent un patient ces
coups de boutoir
ces coups de boutoir
retenue au fond de mon ventre voilà
voilà ça c'est la mort du vieux quoi
pratiquer
à vous de les tuer et donc effectivement
après cette aventure avec ce set up
disons d'un âge mûr
l'héroïne est complètement déboussolée
elle prête à quitter paris et là elle
rencontre le fameux francesco qui est un
riche businessman
alors il ya un truc que je supporte pas
c'est qu'il est fier de frauder le fisc
c'est une image annonce est pas une
image moi je trouve que c'est pas bien
pour ne pas faire de fautes et les
filles je dis je raconte que
qu'effectivement il est comme beaucoup
c'est à dire 20 % de français
aujourd'hui qui se demandent comment ils
vont faire et qui se délocalise c'est
vrai que c'est localise vous dites la
réussite qu'il faut planquer sous peine
de davy d'abus de biens sociaux
c'est pas vrai quand sur l'argent propre
sur lequel on a payé ses impôts on peut
s'acheter tout ce qu'on veut en france
ce qui est interdit c'est s'acheter un
truc est très brouillon de la société
assystem je crois même si c'est très
sain je sais que c'est vachement bien
payer des impôts j'en faisais tout ravi
que moi ça va à quelqu'un ça aide les
gens oui ça c'est des crèches des
hôpitaux dans sérieux et c'est vrai
qu'il faut c'est vrai qu'il
ya des gens qui sont bons ça fait je me
paye des impôts et ne bénéficient pas de
certaines choses comme un citoyen normal
quoi j'appelle la police c'est pas la
même histoire ils viennent quoi qu'il
n'appelle pas de problème
nordnet quand je lis la réussite qu'il
faut planquer sous peine de délit d'abus
de biens sociaux c'est pas vrai quand on
peut s'acheter ce qu'on veut avec
l'argent dit
aujourd'hui quelqu'un qui montrent une
entreprise qui acquis à la force du
poignet pendant des années la montre et
sa propre entreprise à créer de l'emploi
et qui moi c'était ça n'arrive j'entends
ça autour de moi tous les jours et qui
achètent je sais pas j'ai exagère mais
un billet d'avion pour les vacances et
de la vie de mercialys et sa propre
entreprise et c'est
ça les gens font c'est qu'ils s'en
aillent cela parce que je vais vous dire
ça c'est de l'abus de bien social
effectivement s'acheter des billets
d'avion reprendre pour aller en vacances
sur les frais de la société c'est pour
ça c'est un délit c'est un abus de bien
social et c'est interdit et c'est normal
voilà
je vais l'aider le summum enfin quand
même énormément les gens ne connaissent
pas tout ça ils demandent même pour des
petites distances
même pour le net positif si c'est pas
professionnel on paye avec son pote
d'accès comme c'est vrai que ma part et
rihanna flat qui s'en vont et qui suis
seul à côté moi j'ai rien compris ce qui
s'est dit mais qui sont là et on s'en
fout canap la voilà nous on reste non
vraiment je suis là voilà bon alors elle
baise avec francesco donc alors vous
dites un amor reprise
juste martine aubry l'egypte
attendait au marché vous qui avez écrit
un bouquin c'est pas moi
alors ils vont en vacances ensemble et
là ils commencent à porter des sous
vêtements féminins race est
effectivement le mec était ce un show
l'un bien quelle page quelle page 82 je
suis en paix ne se fait plus rageuse et
secoue la palmeraie les partenaires du
musée de jasmin sont enivrantes effluves
le tissu s'envole parce que le mec admis
la nuisette en soi et de l'emploi dans
la métaphore religieuse
les parfums de mer du musée de jasmin
sont des livres en effluves le tissu
s'envole découvrant sa nudité jusqu'à la
taille du mec en retombant tout en
plaquant la soie sur son ventre le pan
de la chemise s'accroche sur son sexe
tendue qu'il laisse ainsi offert commune
assure une provocation
ok je choisis et déjà à ce soit et ligue
2 à ce stade là on voit pas encore la
bip et régis le chemin mais il écoute
pas je ne résiste pas une tentation
brutal nous dit que signe de viège en
cours devant lui je m'agenouille tout se
voir en chaque grand domaine mais ma à
travers le vêtement de peau d'ange je
vais fleurs du bout des doigts qu'est-ce
que j'agis réalité dessinée sous le
velouté du tissu je pu lire mexique
davantage alors ça va jusqu'au dîner à
la fin il ya un dîner où ils arrivent
maquiller le mec fait qu'affirmer poussé
à l'extrême mais pour vous immerger
fruits pas là mais qu'arrive maquillage
ne mélangeons avec un porte jarretelles
parce que je trouve ça aussi
c'est ma mère
m'excuse mais enfin ça va saigner du pif
chez
les messieurs alors à la fin donc ils
font un dîner fin le mec se maquille il
met un porte jarretelles il se couche
par terre c'est des idées pour vous avec
art avec votre canadien et on vous dit
ni feu mais nous sommes les cuisses
serré avec le sexe des mesures et offert
ses plus de la mesure de la mensuration
tout ce qui y est
il me dit prends moi ma chérie donc le
mec est précédée dialogue
et alors c'est le moment où elle la
tâche magie
elle mouille son doigt pour titiller ses
salles le bout de ses seins du mec jeu
mental sur ce pieux démesurée qui me
déchire le ventre est toujours levantin
sait jamais la chatte c'est bizarre pour
un livre de cuisine régionale à cela des
ports même temps tu vas pas la fin parce
que c'est très très chaud si la fin je
peux lui en phrases hyper chaud j'avais
le cul la mine est calciné est incrusté
d'une épaisse croûte noire
à
l'âge de trois ans
l'accès
ah ah
alors oui j'avais effectivement la mine
et helsinn est incrusté d'une épaisse
croûte morts mais qu'est ce que c'est ça
c'est la version bon à nous
mais s'il s'agit des casseroles
là
[Applaudissements]
à
de whisky
je pleure 04 occupe donc servir
eux-mêmes
et tous les aveo les casseroles
ces murs
alors c'est quoi que les films
sérieusement si je sais c'est quoi pour
vous l'homme idéal sérieusement j'y
crois plus à l'homme idéal
c'est un rêve ça de j'ai un amour et je
me suis créé une histoire comme ça et en
écrivant j'ai vécu quelque chose et j'ai
oublié le reste les affaires des de la
couleur de cheveux de l'homme idéal pour
vous brun 1 la coupe de jeu
fort tu m'en fous un peu plus trapu je
voulais lui mais même comme ça je
voulais qu'il soit musclé jusqu'au mans
fois surtout face à rennes pas musclé
mbam effrayer musclé vague à tous les
civils et qu'ils soient beaux enfants
qu'ils aient de l'argent je m'en fous
quel bord politique voulait qu'ils
soient qui fait qu'ils soient d'aucun
bord bien au centre rien du tout
religion je m'en fous la première chose
que l'homme idéal dois vous dire en se
levant
au revoir
[Applaudissements]
et
maintenant
[Musique]
que c'est il resté fidèle
qui comme moi et eux pu aussi bien des
quiévy moins que ça
[Musique]
48e brics voilà ce que pierre dites vous
où
non mais
et voilà ce qu'elle vit une vie de
pierre
ainsi qu'un goût chez les petits nains
pas aussi
six premiers ça va pas mal c'est
lamentable comme d'habitude faisait
comme si ces concerts qui vient effacer
ce cas là je la leur quand ça va c'est
lamentable
c'est assez
bien marré là on est bien barré je sens
bien
le rondin fille qui est quand même un
dramaturge lui aussi je crois qu'on peut
dire c'est vrai heureusement que j'avais
fait un petit bout dans le film de
langue parce que sinon je sais pas ce qu
on retiendrait de votre
d'ailleurs ça a boosté un peu taquin ça
m'a fait ça m'a fait un bien fou
travaillait comme neige puisque j'étais
un peu un peu dans le
plus tôt
et voilà et c'est la sortie d'affaires
vie qui est revenue au top il est au top
là on est au top vous ai vu evelyne chez
michel drucker et quelques temps on nous
a demandés il vous a demandé quelque
chose de très grave il vous a dit est-ce
que c'est pas difficile de jouer avec
l'homme dont on partage la vie c'est
vrai il fallait y penser à celle à 10
ans j'aurais pensé
regarde regarde de ce drame
ce visa est mineure si vous pouviez dire
truc va pas faire une interview trop
pour berlin je vais vous épargner non
monsieur d'une bonne question plus c'est
vrai mais répondait
c'était très bien voilà le dimanche
après midi c'est
bien tu veux contacter deux sont venus
dire si tu es formidable
oui je t'ai mérité mais j'aimerais bien
la faire cette émission de ryan dunn des
gens qui ont des amis oui c'est ça le
fait pas que des amis du bien de dire
que tu es génial tu crois que moi ça
marcherait pas à temps car on a tendance
à
dix minutes près de dix minutes pierre
non sérieusement j'ai lu dans marie
claire du mois de novembre non non mon
père thierry tu évites
j'aime beaucoup marie claire st très bon
la série très sympa j'ai lu comment
comment quoi thierry juste après une
première rencontre un soir dans une
chambre qui servait de loges est venue
une bouille qui s'y présente au nom si
vous à moi j'arrête vous appliquez
m'attendais bien non mais ça j'aimerais
devenir l'avait jamais je vous croyais
pas capable de faire ça c'est à dire que
il le pauvre il est là
et vous le plaqué au mur dès le premier
soir et non à l'or jaune elle vous
plaque au mur c'est dans marie claire
donc c'est vrai vous plaque au mur
buzz en bas ça vous embrasse comme
cinéma et vous dites un vrai baiser de
voyous ces erreurs sonnaient comme ça et
je n'ai écrasé
cinéma quel genre de cinéma parce que
et arditi en plus à l'époque il était
jeune on ne touchait pas être
réfléchis pas ne touchez pas donc il dit
vous l'embrassez vous le coller au mur
et aprilia tout un dégagement sur le
baiser que c'est que finalement on peut
faire l'amour mais tant qu'on embrasse
pas on n'aime pas vraiment que le baiser
c'est le premier le premier acte d'amour
en fin dé lire absolument pousser des
liens bien évidemment c'est comme un
appartement aussi vous embrasser pas
vous aimez pas c'est quand même normal
enfin je ne sais pas c'est vrai que
l'affiché pas comment vous comment ça se
passe pour vous non pas moi
personnellement vais vous montrer
à
c'est lamentable hier voilà pour nos
services à la menthe pour toi bien au
nom pied
[Musique]
ah ouais
ah
bravo long
et ben voilà
j'imagine mais non avec ce tee shirt à
seignosse que plutôt calé au mur à
la la c'est cuit là c'est foutu il faut
que tu le met oui je le mettrais je suis
à la maison je mettrai la prochaine fois
parce que là j'ai déjà un pull moi je
vais crever la non mais je le mettrais
je te prends pas tous crever pierre
mélot
bien donc ce qu'on voit en tous les cas
à la lumière de cette anecdote relatée
dans ma prière incroyable c'est qu'en
fait c'est un petit peu dans votre vie
quotidienne un petit peu comme au cinéma
non non on va voir on va faire une
interview dans la vraie vie
concentrés nous pensons très lourd et
vine aussi est ce que dans la vraie vie
il vous arrive de vous jouer la comédie
l'un à l'autre bah non nous on a le
ballon là on à la comédie et on ouvre la
porte de la maison puis boum un comédie
derrière donc à la maison vous êtes
comme en bas la maison n'a pas besoin de
ça en fait autre chose je vous appelle à
la maison je t'aime maman je t'aime
est ce que est ce que dans la vraie vie
il vous arrive d'entendre des
applaudissements dans les moments de
tendresse ou juste après
oui pourquoi
il ya souvent des coups de théâtre dans
votre vie 3 dans la vraie vie il frappe
les trois coups
j'essaie de deux tant que faire se peut
donc revenir la brigade
alors là c'est pas là
c'est pas lamentable athée notoire
essaye de te penches de transformer la
vie tant que faire se peut en tout cas
le quotidien comme quelque chose qui est
plus magique est plus mystérieux et plus
agréable et plus rigolo tant que faire
se peut alors ça c'est important est ce
que dans la vraie vie vous fait relâche
le lundi
pas du tout non est ce que dans la vraie
vie faisait déjà à trouver un amant dans
le placard
non non donc c'est pas du tout du tout
du tout comme au théâtre finalement la
vraie vie pas vraiment non un entracte
non est ce que dans la vraie vie pierre
il ya une scène que vous ne vous
lasserez jamais de jouer avec evelyne y
en a plusieurs oui j'ai dit oui
il y en a au moins une nuit bien sûr ma
cassette sk une scène dans la vraie vie
que vous voulez plus jamais jouer avec
elle vim
il ya des scènes que je n'aimerais pas
avoir à jouer avec evelyne quoi par
exemple
qu'on jouerait bien honnêtement pour
revenir avec son passé dans des scènes
que je rejoins là il a des souvenirs je
ne vous je ne voulais y est je ne sais
si important dans son nourrir
le parking l'énigme du parti en dehors
de pierres non en dehors de la chambre
la loge et tout ça quand elle vous
accueillir et à d'autres endroits à la
cuisine la cuisine la buanderie je crée
buanderie pierre ne descend pas du tout
on était très voiture nous voilà
voilà voilà voilà
pour la revente tomberait que sa voiture
on a eu de très joli retour de tournage
en voiture
[Musique]
message de la prévention routière n'ont
pas incité les gens à un baiser au
volant parce que ça peut être très
dangereux nous n'étions pas au volant
alors allons-y mes enfants qui
conduisait quoi papa new
heavies du monde
sait que lyon ne sait plus lamentable eh
oui c'est
comme ça
salomé vous êtes la fille de claude
lelouch d'evelyne bouix et vous avez
grandi avec pierre arditi qui était donc
le mari d'evelyne à ce moment là vous
avez débuté au cinéma à l'âge de douze
jours
votre mère savait ce que ça coûte de
quitter l'école trop tôt et elle nous a
interdit de le faire c'est pierre qui
m'a interdit de le faire c'est pierre
qui au moment où j'ai voulu partir de
l'école à 16 ans m'a dit non maintenant
tu ramènes ton cul à l'école et tu passe
ton bac c'est un bon père ce qui est
rare dépit quand même un très bon
qu'est-ce qui est dans l'intimité comme
quand il vient dans cette émission était
toujours c'est lamentable voilà il le
dit aussi bon on pensait que ça nous
était réservé mais non tout bon il le
dit tout le temps le fait bien c'est là
mon regard
on accueille maintenant jean luc
reichmann
jean luc reichmann bonsoir bonsoir
donc quelques mails jean-luc avant de
commencer un mail d'étienne mougeotte
vice président de tf1 où vous animez
tous les jours attention à la marche à
12h05 jean-luc si tu fais plus de 30% de
parts de marché sur les 15 35 chez
ardisson qui virait il le dirait si tu
payes cash pour 100 m y parle un peu
comme chars israéliens
qui crée plus de 3% et je suis sûr
etienne que nous les fros
jean-luc était une voix des guignols
donc effectivement c'est limité tout le
monde alors c'est vrai que etienne
mougeotte lui même n'arrive pas à savoir
qui et fontaines etc et bataille je ne
sais pas alors fontaine je ne boirai pas
de ton dos c'est vrai que le prochain
grand prime time de tf1 c'est 100
meilleures émissions de best of des
meilleures émissions
produits vendus
bien sûr
bien jean-luc reichmann vous avez
déclaré je voulais être coluche mais
c'était déjà pris comme boulot c'est
vrai donc maintenant vous essayez de
prendre le boulot de guy lux non
non j'ai
animé jeux sans frontières c'est vrai et
c'est vrai une saison c'était un bonheur
et là je me suis senti vraiment guy lux
mais given c'est une le regarde avec
charaabi bonsoir chers amis bonsoir et
bienvenue à tout le monde en parle ouais
c'est un bon ville ouais
les quatre auteurs
jimenez aussi
non mais là bas oui aux abris galabru ou
et jean rochefort
galloway non mais on n'est pas là pour
faire on n'est pas là pour faire patrick
sébastien sur la deux a dit nous patrick
sébastien il est génial
génial et puis patrice qui est bien
c'est qu'il fait très bien serge
gainsbourg un zeste de citron c'est
génial
alors jean luc reichmann vous avez
découvert votre don très tôt donc
puisque votre père était directeur de
supermarché et un jour c'est
l'anniversaire du magasin il vous met à
l'animation de la vente des soucis si
vous faites un carton ouais votre
premier carton cas donne en 5 jours 4
tonnes
traitées tranquille
dans les bronzés faisait sa hausse est
alors en fait vos débuts d'animateurs la
radio en 81 ans 87 vous venez à paris
alors votre carrière bon et de la radio
il ya des voix off il ya plein de trucs
à du théâtre aussi dam d'ailleurs gilles
est venu c'est une des rares personnes
qui soit venu c'était une comédie
musicale rock ah oui ta maman est venue
c'était les précieuses ridicules de
molière le texte intégral mais c'était
un roc musical comédie et c'est une des
rares personnes elle était avec alain
bougrain dubourg
ils ont eu un enfant ouais mais blonde
mais ça va pas en quoi c'est ma soeur
d'ailleurs sa boîte ta soeur mandat de
fond les blondes maintenant mandat c'est
toi migaud doit pas défendre les blondes
parce que je n'étais pas du tout
bien donc voilà votre carrière les
précieuses ridicules en rock'n'roll
entre autres des voix de la radio sur
les plus grandes chaînes de radio
nationale mais en fait vous devenez
célèbre jean luc reichmann dans
n'oubliez pas votre brosse à dents ça
dans qu'est ce que demande en part en
part voilà et c'est là où moi j'ai
découvert jean luc reichman le deal en
fait avec ma guise et ai je bien faire
ta voix off mais je parle quand je veux
celui qui m'a laissé le micro ouvert se
souvient un peu comme ma fille ici quoi
oui et ça a été ça a été un
faux nom mais moi je le remercierai
jamais assez c'était gonflé je comprends
montage comme ta gueule là on a bien
intervenir quand vous vouliez oui ça
c'était un grand bonheur il y avait
l'homme qui fait les samplers ici didier
de russan qui était juste à ma gauche et
au samedi à 12h envoie à sampler pour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
certains c'est un grand souvenir avec
génial didier se rappelle
ccc je pense sincèrement alors ensuite
je vais présenter les amours toujours
sur france 2 et alors là évidemment il
ya qu il ya un truc énorme dans les
z'amours j'imagine qu'on vous en parle
toujours c'est un fait le plus rire dans
la vie que c'était quel est l'endroit le
plus torride vous ayez fait l'amour donc
le mari répond tu connais la formule
d'abord c'est le mari qui répond la
femme est cachée de marie répond sur la
table de la cuisine
et la femme répond
on est dans l'anus
posh bisous il ya eu des trucs
extraordinaires il ya la bonne femme qui
voit son mec un jour à l'écran élèves
étaient partis sans laisser d adresse
depuis deux ans ça y est des histoires
extraordinaires mais c'est pas ça c'est
que que ça en fait à la production on
reçoit un coup de fil des ans enfin
voilà bonjour excusez moi j'ai vu une
personne que je connais bien et que
j'aime j'aimerais bien rencontrer tout
ça il est passé hier dans notre émission
en diffusion et effectivement ils
étaient en couple mari et femme et en
fait c'était le mari d'une femme qui
avait disparu depuis deux ans et le mec
est venu sur le plateau avec une autre
femme
et je vous aie aie aie on n'avait jamais
donné l'adresse mais c'est eux c'est
arrivé c'est aller il s'en est passé des
choses est alors un jour jean luc
reichmann en 1999 on découvre à
l'antenne cette tache de naissance sur
votre visage qui avait été jusque là
dissimulé soigneusement par les
maquilleuses et en fait vous déclarez à
ce moment-là il bigot m'a demandé de
choisir entre la tâche et les pompes
jaune oui mais vous avez choisi la tâche
bah oui comme ça j'ai plus de pong jaune
en
2000 après les ponts oui non mais
c'était pour faire un pied de nez parce
que c'est vrai que au début lorsque j'ai
commencé la télé on m'a conseillé de
rentrer
dans un espèce de dounia beaucoup de
tâches à la télé je te le dis ouais et
paray et donc et donc voilà j'ai décidé
d'être moi même et puis c'est tout mais
bon la sphère sexy non en fait oui parce
que en fait ce qui se passe c'est que vu
comment j'ai vu cela non jumeaux ce qui
se passe ici annoncé avant yom c'est
ce qui se passait c'est que quand encore
vous sortir dans la rue non maquillée
dès janvier regardez tout ce dont vous
avez décidé de vous montrer à l'antenne
mais comme dans la rue ouais c'est assez
courageux je trouve ces gentils non
c'est vrai mais ça vous pose pas de rien
du tout ben non mais je me suis je me
sens bien on peut l'enlever maintenant
au laser il ya plein de ya plein de
possibilités et je veux pas l'enlever je
suis né comme ça et j'aime mon rêve
comme ça corbacho tu vois toi quoi moi à
boire mais j'ai pas tache moi non mais
bien faire
laser justement récemment pour un grand
tatouage je t'appelle charlélie couture
maintenant
bon jean luc vous savez qu'ici on dit
tous donc l objet de tous passés en
revue il ya aussi votre petit dérapage
oui vous en souvenez de sa très belle a
raconté où je le raconte à vous le
raconter un jour comme ça il ya
quelqu'un qui gagne et vous dites bravo
ça fait 3 youpi pour patrick et vous
rajouter non ça fait 3 [ __ ] donc bon
voilà c'est le dérapage c'est le vous
repensez après vous dit j'espère que
hugh pas m'en voudront pas c'est là où
c'est devenu un peu grave non mais pas
du tout en fait ce qui sait pas ce qui
se passe quand on fait des jeux télé
comme ça à la chaîne lors de leurs
différents vous le savez je m'appelle
reichmann avec deux attaques est bonne
tout va bien et donc quand on fait 50 ou
60 émission les unes à la suite des
autres on en fait 6 quand on fait des
jeux comme ça je faisais les âmes on
leur faisait six par jour j'étais
fatigué j'en étais à la 55e 56e il ya un
jingle km et youpi youpi et donc est
donc gens chez nous au niveau des
sonorités et c'est un très très mauvais
jeu de mots et s'avère que ils ont
oublié de le couper au montage et c'est
tout simple et j'avais demandé qu'on le
coupé ce n'a pas été coupée et quand on
est fatigué on peut faire des ravages et
c'en est un je me suis excusé je sais le
lendemain et juste pour la petite
histoire c'était assez touchant pour moi
parce que c'est vrai que c'est une
énormité on en dit on en fait je me suis
excusé a juste avant mon émission le
lendemain je vous allez à la direction
de la chaîne aujourd'hui excusez moi
c'est un très mauvais jeu de mots je
m'en excuse pour de vrai je rappellerai
pas un type usés donc avec tous mais
tous mes ascendants est juste pour la
petite anecdote il y à un monsieur un
joueur qui est arrivé lors d'une
conférence de presse et qui m'a dit j'ai
vu ce que tu as fait et tu es la seule
personne qui ait eu le courage de faire
ça avant une émission le lendemain et et
depuis je te regarde totalement
différemment et j'ai beaucoup de respect
depuis ce jour là pour alain delon parce
que c'était alain delon qui me l'a dit
et me dit mais ils n'ont pas compris que
tu t'appelais reichmann way et j'ai été
très touché par ce match l'affairé close
alors texte vous a remplacé aux amours
mais vous le trouvez comment très très
sympa un connard
ses hobbies à meuh non non non non j'en
ai croisé mais pas du nom mais c'est un
autre style sais je sais il sait très
bien il est très bien dans d'autres dans
ce rôle là jamais présenté et alors ça
m'a beaucoup amusé l'ère de la présente
étude a pas présenté après bat
facilement pas voulu j'ai pas j'étais
passé bien oui c'est toi oui toi la
maison dire aux jeunes attention c'est
quoi le micro de jean tend le micro d'un
mandat
c'est parce que je vis dans les st
laurent j'y vais
mais dakar dakar et
laurent intervient enfin on va faire le
18 à chaque fois alors bien et l'a donc
cher jean luc reichmann nous inventer
attention à la marche en fait france 2
n'en veut pas et vous allez le faire sur
tf1 oui avec beaucoup de succès et je
crois que c'était maintenant ça marche
bien je suis très bien et ça marche bien
c'est bon alors l'émission est basé sur
des sondages étonnant par exemple 27%
des femmes m enlever les points noirs de
leur conjoint
combien de % et 7 % écoutez un truc qui
m'avait vachement étonné ckeck c'était
quoi la question je viens de
sur sa femme combien de femmes d ont
déjà dans leurs vies déchirées les
habits de leurs hommes ouais combien
voilà combien combien tu dis toi 16% non
mais ben non c'est comme la non mais
j'avais dit 90 et ont fait céder 30
c'est vachement la défense et non comme
une fille pas déjà tout gagné par
rapport à celle ayant barré fille mais
c'est le décolleté il faut bien la
région racicot log est prévue d'ici qui
s'est aperçu social interne
tu arrêtais charléty mais pas animé tu
prends pas
un suma suma je n'avais pas du tout à
leur demande s'ils
sont dégueulasses d'ariane à une autre
c'est par exemple combien d'hommes porte
un string tous les jours at on avait 14
% non 1% excuse moi toi tu vois des mecs
qui sont pas normaux là
ouais combien combien de filles
pratiquent l'appellation c'est pas de 39
pour 65 cents
l'armée a détruit près de 9 % des
français pensent que les trains roulent
plus vite la nuit paraît sain et sauf ça
extraordinaire c'est moi je pense que ça
aussi je fais partie de ma part je
pensais que les trains de nuit où les
pluies dont il y avait personne sur les
voies
qui m'intéresse il est vachement bien
son bouquin ya plein de trucs sont des
fins de traitements que savoir mettre un
préservatif avec la bouche ah oui tu
sais le faire ça enfin
68 % des français pensent qu'il faut pas
tout dire à leurs conjoints
68% ça fait beaucoup quand même
voilà et vous pensez qu'il faut te dire
à son conjoint quand ça fait mal non je
pense pas je pense que effectivement on
peut ne pas tout dire non pas mentir
mais pas rien dire pas de se dire mais
justement on va faire une interview et
vous janvier
driss ans quand tu as fait des
compliments tout à l'heure on a chanté
ses louanges essaie de nous envoyer un
jingle qui bave pas comme ça
alors jean luc reichmann 10% des hommes
aiment les femmes aux seins siliconés
c'est dans votre livre et vous
je dois vous avouer qu'aujourd'hui je
suis allé au salon de l'agriculture
ouais
j'aime bien nature et
8% des hommes ne portent pas de
sous-vêtements ce qui est mon cas
d'ailleurs alors il vous portez des
sous-vêtements oui l'été de temps en
temps non 54% des français se sont déjà
cogné la tête contre le mur en faisant
l'amour et vous je roule en deux roues
je porte un casque
19 % des femmes ont déjà mesuré le sexe
de leur conjoint et vous
sa honda 1000 baisse de son ca
extraordinaire
maintenant moi je me suis jamais fait
rien fait du tout et vous ai mesuré le
sexe de votre femme non et vous moi je
vais vous conter jeunes bien sûr on peut
jouer à ça bien sûr entière 1-1 s'est
pas aventuré quand j'étais étudiant à
montpellier oui il ya une femme qui vous
êtes déjà mesurer leur jouer à ça bien
sûr bah oui quand on est alors combien
alors je me suis maintenant
vous êtes
je ne dirais pas avoir honte voilà
bien sûr c'est génial a plus et moi et
d'expansion cherche pas d'excusés
de la
biennale à l'idée qu'on va appeler sa
mère va nous dire 8 85% des hommes
justement pensent que leur sexe et de la
bonne taille et vous avez très bien ah
oui ça va
je ne sais pas si les gens assis ça
c'est intéressant à 16% des hommes sont
dérangés par les cris excessif de leur
partenaire et vous ce n'est pas eu une
fois c'est horrible away ah ouais on est
gêné
10% des français font l'amour tous les
jours et vous savez ça m'arrive quand je
suis en forme tous les ménages là où je
rêve a tourné pendant les vacances se
quitter
[Musique]
badiane est devant toi
sardo same as roma risque reste mais ça
va ce qui en reste vous avez reçu ici
pour votre premier roman qui s'appelle
pardonnez nos offenses le lit venait de
sortir et depuis vous en avez vendu 280
mille exemplaires et s'est traduit dans
10 pays les compteurs votre père mon
père est très content oui c'est bien ah
oui c'est bien non c'était fin j'étais
le premier surpris je pensais pas je me
doutais qu'on allait en parler
évidemment ou qu'ils allaient avoir un
petit un petit coup de projecteur dessus
pour des raisons externes à la
littérature mais enfin bon on en vend
pas 280 mille exemplaires parce qu'on
est le fils de michel faisant non les
gens étaient contents donc je suis ravie
je continue
votre père dites-vous il à plus
d'imagination que le feu secrète oui on
associe le feu sacré à la scène plutôt
sympa non alors vous savez que votre
père l'a souvent invité dans cette
émission on a même eu son smoking en
vente bon il va venir lâche t il n'est
pas venu pour rien qui nous en veut mais
j'en sais rien je vais lui demander
devrait parvenir sa réponse on sait rien
non mais il fait pas beaucoup beaucoup
de télé est un art n'est pas
rée des nouvelles devaient se méfier de
vous un peu quand même vous avez des
nouvelles de lui a batu le temps anciens
bons à faire une interview vous avez des
nouvelles
[Musique]
est ce que il regrette toujours le temps
béni des colonies le toubib les colonies
non je pense pas mais il n'a jamais
regretté un c'est un petit joue un
personnage dans cette chanson oui c'est
pas parce que quand il chante je suis
pourri pense aux strings pour hommes
austin powers france parle et ce qui
fait toujours l'amour en chantant
toujours
d'histoire et de son statut permet c'est
l'unique sur le s qui forgent toujours
la gueule dans les bals populaires ou
bien et préfère saint tropez maintenant
à noyers plus belles populaire à saint
tropez en pas trop tu veux toujours pas
qu'on l'appelle france toujours
il aime toujours les ricains nom de
moins en moins ouais ouais il a été il
n'était pas trop bon ça c'est une longue
histoire mais non pas qu'ils les
américains pour ce qu'ils ont fait ils
ont fait comme tout le monde est
complètement con pour dire tout mélanger
mais sur le sur le final et d'ailleurs
il n'y va plus ils allaient tout le
temps les états unis veulent ils avaient
toujours en france suffisamment la
france beaucoup mieux que ce qu'on dit
non tu es beaucoup encore s'il se corse
is beaucoup ça doit être l'âge
est ce que il pense au sida quand il dit
elle court elle court la maladie d'amour
il y pensait pas à l'époque en tout cas
c'est s'était pas d'actualité pour ce
qui viendra un jour dans cette émission
j'ai des doutes quand même ah oui oui
c'est pas possible je pense pas qu'il
sera à l'aise dans ce genre de match
mais bon je vais pas répondre à sa place
mais je pense pas que c'est pas trop pas
trop son truc
et
m
bonsoir moi ça ça va crier traque un peu
un petit peu c'est normal je combats
tout va bien je suis d'être là je suis
ravi que vous soyez là alors vous êtes
la fille cynthia de la première épouse
de michel sardou françoise pétré qui à
l'époque était danseuse au châtelet vous
êtes né en 1973 en même temps que romain
sardou nous avons reçues souvent ici
alors à l'époque où vous n'essayez donc
de l'épousé de michel sardou romain
n'essaie de babette qui à l'époque
n'était pas encore la femme n'était pas
encore la deuxième femme de michel
sardou mais était sa maîtresse c'est ça
mon à wade car voilà voilà alors michel
voulait un garçon est de toute évidence
c'était pas vous c'était pas moi c'était
pas moi et je pense que
bon je l'est
comment expliquer ça dès que j'ai de mon
père j'étais une erreur quoi oui je le
pense sincèrement et je d'ailleurs je
mets pas honte de ce que j'ai écrit je
n'ai pas honte de ce que je suis
aujourd'hui parce que je suis une fille
et je suis ravi d'être une fille
tellement parce que c'est un garçon à
l'époque voila voila moi excusez moi et
alors votre mère vous en à votre mère
vous on a voulu en fait parce qu'elle a
la pensée elle s'est imaginé que le fait
que vous soyez une fille à aider michel
à se séparer d'elle en faites vous un
petit peu rendu responsable on y perçoit
dit oui on est toujours persuadé
aujourd'hui oui oui oui parce que j'ai
d'ailleurs il ya une lettre qui me le
prouve ouvertement et que je que je que
j'intègre dans l'histoire donc
effectivement je même trente ans après
vous voyez c'est visiblement cessé
rester et vous donc vous avez grandi
avec ce sentiment de culpabilité
c'est à dire que vous sentir un peu
responsable de leur rupture
je me suis complètement senti
responsable de cette rupture déjà parce
que j'ai
j'ai pas vécu je peux pas dire que j'ai
eu une enfance parce que j'en ai pas eu
mon père a effectivement
donné ce qu'il fallait pour notre
éducation en revanche
moi je n'ai je ne me pense je ne
considère pas avoir reçu l'éducation je
me suis éduquer tout seul je m'étais
créé un monde à moi dans ma tête un
monde merveilleux qui m'a permis de
résister absolument à tous c'est à dire
dans mon mental c'est mon mental qui a
fait que j'ai résisté à toute la
violence
que le japon n'a alors à l'époque où
vous naissez michel sardou est en train
de devenir une méga vedette vraiment une
star nationale est en fait vous décrivez
l'envers du décor c'est à dire que par
exemple dont il est très sympa comme ça
que tu avec des gens et quand il à la
maison mais un cendrier déplacer il
rentre dans une colère noire il lance
des regards absolument terrible aux gens
enfin c'est oui
il est il est comme ça après son divorce
michel sardou épouse babette donc sa
seconde épouse et votre mère épouse dit
tu vois un pseudo producteur de musique
que vous ne que vous ne citez pas vous
donnait pas son nom et lui est intéressé
en fait par les relations de votre mère
par le carnet d adresse de votre mère
par l'argent que votre père verse à
votre mère mais en fait vous l'appelez
le funeste d'ailleurs ça sera jamais
quelqu'un de positif pour vous en tous
les cas
d'ailleurs je tiens à préciser que pour
moi il s'agit bien là criminels en
liberté c'est parce que c'est un
personnage terry parce qu'il exige que
vous l'appeliez papa mais il vous bas et
ils vous battra pendant des années en
fait pendant ben j'ai vécu dans cet
entourage pendant plus de 15 ans oui
donc quand vous vivez ça tous les jours
et antigua ans et il ya un moment il
faut partir il faut s'en aller mais
votre mère dit rien
ben visiblement non elle est je dirais
que c'est ma mère était une absente
une absente avec un grand a et il n'y a
pas je pense que quand on aime quelqu'un
l'amour parfois peut aller si loin qu'on
on en est un est aveugle de tout ce qui
se passe autour et je pense que oui et
là c'était un moyen pour elle de le
garder que d'accepter ce qu il vous
faisait subir en fait
peut-être
qu'envoyer michel sardou ça se passe pas
mieux parce que vous voyez très peu mais
quand vous voyez par exemple une fois
vous avez 5 ans il est très dur avec
vous un jour vous refusé d'évacuer la
salle de bains et vous traite de tas de
merde quand même quoi oui c'est vrai
c'est vrai j'avais 5 ans et je m'en
rappelle pas c'est d'ailleurs c'est même
étonnant mais la psychanalyse à faire
remonter encore des choses à la surface
parce qu'on croit toujours tout est
enfoui et qu'on oublie mais en fait
c'est en soit ce
et après ça il s'est pas excusé quoi
michel sardou s'excuse rarement
général alors les bons moments
finalement c'est avec votre grand mère
jackie sardou alors là ça se passe super
bien à quoi c'est vraiment quelqu'un de
boue
oui qui a été très présente et
d'ailleurs même dans des contextes je
dirais
complètement loufoque parce qu'elle
était elle à el alami le scandale dans
un restaurant un jour et c'était très
drôle finalement bon c'était une femme
exceptionnelle c'est une grande dame
c'est une grande comédienne parce que je
pense qu'on lui a pas rendu hommage
comme il aurait fallu le faire et
j'avais envie de le faire
et ça me fait bien plaisir
alors
ce qui est terrible pendant toute votre
enfance en fait c'est que le sujet
michel sardou chez vous êtes un tabou
c'est à dire qu'on n'en parle pas sauf
pour dire que c'est un abruti ou alors
quand il passait la télé aux arts donc
en plus vive est dans le déni de votre
père pendant toute votre enfance et
votre adolescence oui je dis rond
on était on nous a fait aussi du
bourrage de crâne pendant très longtemps
et ça je le il faut être il faut le dire
aussi et donc effectivement quand vous
avez du bourrage de crâne pendant tout
ce temps vous il était fait normal
qu'elle a au bout du compte vous du 10
bon ben ok ben non quoi c'est
effectivement ça peut
cède sa 10e saga ch les relations quoi
qu'il arrive alors je disais en
commençant que votre livre était
extrêmement bouleversant parce que vous
vivez et finalement dans cette maison où
on critique votre père sans arrêt quand
vous voyez votre père et vous traite de
tas de merde et pour vos 12 ans votre
beau-père vous roue de coups carrément
vous êtes complètement recroquevillé
tout ça donc à un moment évidemment on
est on sait très bouleversant cette
histoire on souffre pour vous quand vous
êtes dans l'incapacité de bouger et
quand vous effectivement vous êtes au
sol et que vous pouvez pas bougé pendant
un temps la seule arme qui vous reste
c'est votre esprit et c'est ce qui s'est
produit également dans la tentative de
meurtre hier que votre mental quand je
oui il reste que ça pour finalement
trouver pour garder pour rester en vie
c'est un instinct de survie est ce que
votre beau-père il boude pas parce que
vous recevez des copines en pantoufles
par exemple moi je mange je me suis
demandée sincèrement ce que je faisais
là je n'avais rien à faire là et c'est
logique vous partez un moment donné
parce qu'il n'ya pas y'a rien à faire
y'a rien à alors justement cynthia quand
vous partez pour pour faire des études
tout ça vous vous apercevez qu'en fait
le fric que michel sardou donne à votre
mère votre beau-père le garde pour lui
donc en plus j'ai même pas les moyens de
faire des études on va vous être
complètement bloqué vous à vous avez je
me suis offert une année super j'ai
voulu le faire j'ai travaillé pour ça
j'ai travaillé pour payer mes études et
finalement même si c'était pas
énorme et j'ai fait ce que j'ai pu ouais
tout simplement vous êtes courageuse
c'est vrai et malgré tout un moment où
vous pensez à vous suicider quand même
oui effectivement
et c'est un clochard je te sourit par
une page un alcoolique mais sauve la vie
c'est formidable formidable c'est
formidable alors vous commencez à vous
en sortir vous commencé à bosser jackie
sardou vous faire entrer chez daniel
filipacchi comme maître d'hôtel est
excellente et sympa j'ai filipacchi
assez
bien tous très bien voilà vous fait des
petits boulots des petits jobs vous
commencez à vous intégrer à la société
vous commencez à exister vous travaillez
à i télévision donc qu est une filiale
info du groupe canal plus et là un soir
voilà vous quittez vous quittez
itélévision vous rentrez chez vous et
dans le parking de votre immeuble vous
êtes carrément enlever
par trois matches j'ai été suivie en
voiture et puis j'ai été enlevée dans ma
voiture
oui
trois mecs qui vont vous violez pendant
pendant deux heures on m'a enlevé
séquestré avec un couteau bien sûr enfin
couteau est pas loin en tout cas
et puis bon ben j'ai jeu et en plus je
sais même pas où on m'emmène je sais pas
ce qui va m'arriver
effectivement on peut s'attendre à tout
parce que quand on voit les visages le
visage d'un criminel et qu'on peut le
reconnaître effectivement
d'ailleurs j'étais à deux doigts
d'exploser dans mon auto donc c'était
alors à ce moment-là votre mec vous
lâche et un moment sardou pour vous
rejoindre à ce moment-là à un accrochage
donc tunnel de la défense et se brisent
le match là c'est vraiment un un
enchaînement de choses absolument
absolument terrible et et vous vous
trouver refuge en fait chez michel
sardou qui vient de se remarier donc
pour la pour la troisième fois avec anne
marie périer vous commencez à vivre un
peu chez eux c'est lui qui vous le
propose en fait et au bout d'un moment
il vous le reproche oui
oui effectivement il ya un juste un mois
tout juste après les faits j'avais quand
même dans le sang
un traitement du vih qui est quand même
difficile à supporter parce qu'en plus
j'ai repris le travail dix jours après
et je suis retourné à la chaîne j'ai
très bon j'étais en traitement
thérapeutique est effectivement j'avais
toujours dans l'est dans ma tête je me
demandais si j'allais avoir le sida ou
pas
effectivement je
oui j'étais donc je travaillais à la
chaîne je rentrais le soir et tout ça et
puis effectivement il ya un bien
un matin j'ai été j'ai eu
effectivement une engueulade avec mon
père en privé et g
jérôme a foutu dehors quoi [ __ ] qui
vous reprochent de squatter non
seulement son appartement mais sa femme
et puisqu'à pire que tout ce qui vous
dit que vous mangez du poisson et que ça
lui coûte plus cher que la viande ça
j'avoue que ça m'a complètement mais je
peux pas manger de viande serait
impossible pour moi je ne pouvais pas
parce que suite au fait c'était
impossible cela et parce que je
je ne forçait pas jeu et je me suis
forcée en plus de ça parce qu'il m'a
quand même fait manger de la viande je
ne dis pas mais c'est pas grave ouais
alors il vous dit que vous êtes nuls que
votre thérapie c'est de la merde enfin
vraiment on peut pas dire qu'ils qui
vous aide et il ce qui est
extraordinaire dans cette histoire c'est
qu'en fait vous en auriez pas parlé on
l'aurait jamais susi a que tous les
journaux tous les magazines français les
radios les télévisions ont accepté de ne
pas parler de votre de votre viol
est alors lui en fait il va pas au
procès
justement pour pas qu'on en parle c'est
mal je ne demandais pas à ce qu'il soit
là parce qu'effectivement la presse
aurait pu attirer il aurait pu attirer
l'attention de la presse justement en
revanche un coup de téléphone ou un
petit mot gentil avec un bouquet de
fleurs ça fait de mal à personne
alors vos agresseurs sont condamnés à 15
13 et 10 ans de prison ce qui est plutôt
plutôt bien non plutôt pas mal mais
alors votre père qui a toujours parlé de
faire justice lui même qui a toujours
dit qu'il était pour la peine de mort il
à laisser la justice faire son travail
sans intervenir sur ce coup là
effectivement
alors quelles ont été les réactions de
michel sardou à votre livre il a eu une
très bonne réaction il a très bien réagi
à ça et c'est plutôt agréable à entendre
et jeu je suis ravi j'adore harry bosch
dans l'eure
j'en sais rien il a dit qu'il
reconnaissait qu'il n'avait pas été un
bon père d'une certaine façon droit si
oui est ce que vous pensez pas que
michel sardou s'est comporté comme ça
avec vous parce que lui aussi a été
finalement il n'a pas eu ses parents il
était en pension moncel il voyait
rarement son père armand sa mère est
peut-être celle là pas habitué à être un
bon père d'une certaine façon non c'est
pas juan veut même pas d'avoir été
absent non moi je parce que je ne lui en
veux pas d'avoir été absent parce qu'un
artiste déjà ne se comporte pas comme
quelqu'un de normal c'est pas quelqu'un
de normal un artiste un artiste c'est
quelqu'un n'a pas d'à par différents des
autres qui est qui reste dans une eau
qui qui est solitaire et donc je ne lui
en veut pas d'eux
d'avoir été absent parce que je sais
qu'il a donné ce qu'il fallait donc je
lui en veux pas pour ça d'ailleurs je ne
lui en veux pour rien moi je suis parti
et je j'avais des raisons très
personnelles de le faire et d'ailleurs
j'ai écrit cède ce témoignage parce que
j'ai eu d'autres pressions aux états
unis et que j'en ai eu assez mais quelle
pression je vais aux états j'ai eu des
coups de fil désagréable et j'en ai pas
ce que j'avais écrit ce témoignage au
départ pour moi et j'en ai eu assez de
supporter parce que tout ça ça fait
remonter la peur et mon passé et j'en ai
eu assez je me suis dit que les gens
avaient le droit de savoir ouais c'est
tout d'où les vues pour la dernière fois
michel soeur d'eau
gelée vu il ya deux ans et demi c'était
juste avant mon départ aux états unis
ouais pas de plus au théâtre
toujours d'ailleurs j'ai j'ai ici et
vous a téléphoné depuis l'apparition du
livre non
vous pensez que ce livre va aider ou à
graver votre relation avec lui déjà il
n'y a pas de relation pour l'instant
donc il n'ya pas de dialogue
effectivement et d'ailleurs je ne
cherche pas en avoir moi j'ai fait un
choix je suis parti parce que c'était la
seule façon de m'en sortir
maintenant je vous dis sincèrement que
si je continue à être embêté là-bas et
si on continue
je vais pas non plus pousser loin les
pressions mais j'irai jusqu'au bout
vous regrettez pas de ne pas lui avoir
dit tout ça de vive voix plutôt qu'à
travers un livre à votre père j'ai
essayé de le faire une fois et
ça il n'y a pas de dialogue le dialogue
ne passe pas je les aime mes parents je
les relis pages remis personne sauf que
il ya un moment il n'y a plus il se
passe rien qu'est ce que vous voulez
faire qu'est ce que vous voulez faire je
veux dire il n'ya pas il n'y a pas
d'issue vous pouvez pas changer les gens
monsieur le ministre le mot de la fin on
cherche un peu gêné par don de vous le
dire parce que je crois que dans les
affaires privées vraiment quand il
s'agit de la vie des couples la vie
amoureuse des gens la vie affective
avec ses parents personnes non seulement
ne de juger mais personne n'a le droit
de juger on peut pas dire qu'on dise des
vérités ya pas de vérité dans ces
affaires là quand des gens sait pas
quand des gens se fâchent entre parents
enfants entre six proches que ça entre
mari et femme personne n'a le droit ni
le pouvoir de savoir ce qui s'est passé
vraiment et donc je suis au fond ce que
vous dites là il faut probablement c'est
à lui que vous le dit d'ailleurs mais
folien votre père peut-être à votre
analystes mais au fond je faciaux qui
est vraiment du courage à le publier
puis je suis pas sûr que ce soit bon
pour vous voilà mais bon il faudrait en
parler un peu plus longuement mais dans
ces affaires-là ne croyez pas que
personne ne pense qu'on puisse dire hors
il est mauvais il a tort il a raison ou
la pauvre le haut le méchant on ne peut
jamais savoir comment ça se passe
peut-être que ce que vous dites est
entièrement vrai mais de toute façon moi
je ne le saurai jamais personne ici ne
pourra jamais juger et l'anti peut-être
sont des choses qu'il faut le dire à lui
mais pas mais pas aux autres et donc je
suis toujours un peu gêné quand la
sphère privée s'étale en public alors
que bon voila vous livrer sa
au chien si je puis dire à des gens qui
vont dire du mal de lui dire c'est un
sale odeur mais personne n'en saura
jamais rien ici oui mais c'est votre
affaire avec lui et soul et il faut
régler ça avec son père n'est pas avec
les autres sardou est très secondaire
dans mon histoire quand enfin si ce
n'était pas lui on n'en parlerai pas ici
simplement que j'ai vraiment peur qu'en
passant du très privé comme ça au public
vous soyez extrêmement déçu après parce
que le jugement des autres a
probablement aucun rapport avec ce que
vous avez vécu en tout cas n'attendez
pas de qui comprenne forcément ce que
vous disiez ou qu'ils puissent être
jugeant l'affairé quand on écrit un
livre et qu'on le déchirent pas après
c'est quand même qu'on a besoin d'eux
des autres pour comprendre pour juger ce
qu'on a vécu et quand c'est des affaires
très privée je crois qu'on risque d'être
de se tromper d'être déçu voilà c'est ce
qu'à ça je voulais vous dire sur tout
mais pas ses points méchanceté vous
répondre simplement que le crime n'a pas
de visage et que quel que soit le
contexte social vous vous soyez le crime
arrive n'importe où n'importe quand et
qu'il n'y a pas de lieu
et en revanche il n'y a pas de
tout peut arriver dans une existence
tout est possible et rien n'est
impossible dans le cours d'une existence
et c'est ça le message
et maintenant voici marilyn manson
vous voulez qu'on fasse rentrer mon
invité sur place et une réaction par
rapport à certains emails qu'on a reçu
c'est vrai qu'on n'est pas des puristes
on n'est pas forcément des linguistes
mais des gens qui sont irrités derrière
leur poste parce qu'il nous arrive
parfois de faire surtout à toile thierry
ce que moi je suis pas là serait souvent
il nous arrive de faire des fautes de la
série qui s'est donc vite et yoda mon
maître qui va être là juste pour
contrôler que les taux de remplacement
sera correct bugs mais le maître capello
tout de suite
capello dont l'invité surprise de la
liste
soir d'ivoire
c'est uniquement
la vertu qu'ils aient vu c'était aux
folies bergères on faisait double jeu et
on a fumé un pétard ensemble après les
après l'émission ça m'étonnerait
beaucoup à la moi ça m'étonne pas du
tout hein alors simplement maître
capello est là pour un peu superviser
compte tenu des belles construction de
phrase et puis faire la chasse à me la
chasse aux barbarisme et au foot en
général d'accord mère d'accord
d'ailleurs je veux soutien des grains ce
que vous reprochez le 23 avril sans
liaison ouais c'est vous qui avez raison
ce que je vous dit 3 avenue la liaison
oui mais dans 3 avril appsteur vers ça
ne me fait pas
peur
il est
oui
non
déchiré ses lettres de mécontents il
arrêtait la dope apparemment j'avais
arrêté les mois besoin de juin d'accord
c'est bien m bien vous restez avec nous
donc à 100 at il dit
il en tire à vue
tu es resté c'est toutes les semaines
bien tu vas voir à quel point il est
précieux
donc je vais être un petit peu la
dompteuse demain c'est à dire que c'est
une sorte
ok
ma
fille décide de vraiment devenir une âme
et vous savez de quoi ai-je pas quand
même basse et sait rien on collectionne
d'accord bah oui pour montrer qu'on s'en
fout quoi non pas du tout une [ __ ]
pas dominer ce
set que je maîtrisais irakien et la robe
peut en tout cas aider beaucoup
d'associations humanitaires des
parfaitement bilingue et elle est
parfaitement bilingue mairie du
applaudissements
leur marche tout seul
le mourre irak bien dire le rivage oui
série paye à ce prix j'ai le peuple me
répétant très bien merci
le zapping lundi
sa guinguette que du rivage de quoi
tigres y fera bien sauver la mésopotamie
c'est entre les deux fleuves parce que
mary où céline yeux potamot c'est vrai
entre le tigre et l'euphrate il braille
et
services que l'udc avant nicolas nuss un
resto
c'est bien connu
le beyond aux bretons veut dire le petit
halloween et grands à le bio ça veut
dire le petit bébé alors qu'attend gti
décrypte tous extraordinaires c'est
normal ouais et où ça veut dire quoi
rouve route c'est le chien groupe c le
chat louis
ou quoi leroux remplace son camp gaulois
manger du gaulois par maître marc
italien
d'imagina le petit
aurait alors samuel a même parlé du film
qui vous amène ici j'aurais qu on
revienne quelques instants à la case
départ qu'on fasse une espèce de n'est
pas un espèce mais je sais même espèce
[Musique]
tombé dans le piège
c'est un peu compliqué soir qui est
l'islam été surprise de gatti donc on
est obligé n'impressionne pas deux fois
quoi
[ __ ] se profile la crème du loup s'est
excusé moi va être bien non mais vous
avez déjà fait de la boxe toute façon
avant d'entamer différence est en mesure
j'en ai fait un petit peu oui mais
j'aimais ça ouais mais là j'étais
coachée par stéphane ferrara si tous
n'ont pas cessé bien d'accord oui
non mais laurent le met sur pause de
temps en temps mais le problème c'est
qu'il se démarque tout seul pas la route
mais
comment dans quelles catégories
des bonbons j'ai des poids moyens et
je ferai tout le monde tu es tu si vous
osiez jeu de mots ma protège
[Applaudissements]
j'accueille marilyn manson
bonsoir
vous parliez de drogue tout à l'heure
j'étais même pas encore arrivé bonsoir
marilyn donc vous appelez marilyn comme
monroe et manson comme charles manson ça
vous est venu comment cette idée
d'accoupler le nom d'un tueur en série
satanistes avec le prénom d'une icône
glamour de l'amérique
je voulais être la meilleure
représentation possible de l'amérique
votre surnom ses entés christ superstar
cela c'est bien que vous en pensez hervé
hanté christ superstar
c'était le nombre
d'albums la relève est assurée et
marilyn manson est une star donc du
shock rock ce qu'on peut appeler le
shock rock alors dans la tradition de
badis toons avec sympathy for the devil
ensuite il est black sabbath avec ozzy
osbourne alice cooper les sexpistols je
suis anarchiste je suis l'antéchrist
chantait johnny rotten on est très
contents de vous avoir ce soir parce que
vous êtes une star mondiale marilyn
juste thierry un e-mail qui va nous
tomber beaucoup de gens règlent leur
téléviseur tout ça est normal
qu'est ce que les gens croient qu'ils
regardent de chiens à la fois une
ceinture et maître capello une scène
marilyn manson pas du tout c'est la même
chaîne c'est france 2 bien on va
commencer par le début manson vous êtes
né le 5 janvier 69 et votre vrai nom
c'est brian hugh warner
votre père était un ancien mécanicien
d'hélicoptère au vietnam
mais je me trompe jamais moi iwasaki
quel monde ils gérer une magasin de
meubles et
il est seul moment d'intimité de votre
père avec vous c'était quand ils vous
emmener au stand de tir pour vous
apprendre à tirer ça c'était un vrai
moment d'intimité avec lui et puis aussi
il vous emmener au concert de kiss un
biais neutre et 12 ans mon père abel
justement maquillage qui s'est mal un
concert dans cette tenue
papa était cool
ça c'est votre papa votre maman celle
inverse elle a été très très possessive
traître est étouffante comme ça et quand
vous êtes petit marilyn manson vous
passez beaucoup de temps chez vos
grands-parents et vous découvrez la
sexualité dans la cave de votre grand
père voilà alors dans la cave du
grand-père à ça te plait ça jenna
alors dans la cave du grand-père de
marilyn y avait quoi matri capello dans
la cave du grand père du matin
il y avait des nuages qui avait avait de
la lingerie féminine
il y avait des godemichés enduits de
vaseline les godemichés 1
et puis aussi des photos zoophiles à
aillas est assez juste sauvé c'est très
drôle de grand père
quand j'étais gamin mon grand-père me
paraissait monstrueux mais en
grandissant je me suis rendu compte que
mon grand-père était bonne je suis comme
lui il est pas si mal que ça
que j'aime pas trop les animaux dans les
faits la zoophilie ce qui n'a pas tiré
un cheval dans ces heurts
moi j'étais la paix
j'aime pouvoir sont alors donc vous aide
à l'école à l'héritage christiane school
à et là évidemment pardon parce qu'il a
aussi
agi dans ce sens que j'aime en faire un
ami de capello merci même plus
donc voila vous allez dans cette école
donc on vous inculque des valeurs
fondées sur l'antéchrist et sur
l'apocalypse alors évidemment ça à tout
çà çà çà travail dans votre tête vous
essayez de vous adapter à l'école vous
essayez de vous adapter et un jour vous
leur apportez
une photo c'est des nuages dans le ciel
qui représente 1 en manches et lui parce
qu'ils pensent là un vous pensez leur
faire plaisir
c'était ma grand mère qui m'avait
ils m'ont dit que c'était un faux et
donc
c'était la seule fois où j'essaie de
m'intégrer vraiment dans ce but qu'on
m'a dit tout ça c'était du bidon mais
j'ai arrêté j'ai arrêté de croire ou des
c3 à ce que me racontait est alors au
lieu de vivre dans la peur d'avoir des
cauchemars et plat j'ai décidé de
devenir ce dont j'avais peur juste mais
voilà alors là c'est la révolte dès
l'âge de 12 ans vous vous révoltez vous
êtes attiré par tout ce qui est interdit
vous êtes à l'époque vous est maigre
vous êtes couvert de boutons vous êtes
toujours tout seul en face vous avez une
adolescence ça c'est assez terrible en
moi je me sentais invisible et de
transparence c'était page été rejetée
j'étais vraiment invisible on ne me
voyait pas et ça ne l'est qu'à travers
la musique ou l'écriture quand j'étais
gamin je me suis dit je serai artistes
les écrivains je pensais que j'allais
chanter parce que je ne savais pas
chanter mais bon et c'est comme ça que
j'ai trouvé ma propre voie je crée mon
monde et alors là en compagnie d'un
certain john cromwell et de son grand
frère au lycée vous commencé à vous
intéresser aux sciences occultes aux eau
qu une bonne nuit
dans un football un tube non non mais
c'est bien parce que comme ça ça
cautionne et c'est une bonne idée non
c'est le service public service public
c'est bien donc vous intéresser avec ce
dénommé john cromwell aux sciences
occultes aux doctrines satanique 1 c'est
l'époque où vous visiter disneyland eux
sous acide des
ca propose cet épisode rappelle un peu
cet épisode un peu surréaliste et là où
fait de la scène donc c'est le scandale
évidemment vous masturber sur scène un
faux pénis qui éjacule un liquide de
improbable vous jeter des n'a pas eu
recours à un accessoire de
vous jeter des poulets vivants au public
mais c'est vrai que c'est le public qui
les égorge
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non non
tâchez de l'homme
c
[Musique]
au sujet de votre cinquième album sur le
précédent vous avez déclaré c'est
l'histoire d'un innocent qui veut faire
partie d'un monde qui ne l'acceptent pas
il se bat il découvre sa révolution et
finit par devenir un objet marketing
aujourd'hui vous êtes devenu un objet
marketing
ce que je fais je l'exploité et d'en
faire ils ont une marchandise et bien il
yal'affaire donc de colomb aïn donc
cette université du michigan où deux
fans ouvrent le feu sur leurs camarades
et les médias américains vous accuse
alors vous répondez on peut pas accuser
shakespeare de pousser les gens au
suicide parce qu'il a écrit roméo et
juliette enfin c'est vrai quand même que
les gens qui ont tiré sur leurs
camarades étaient des fans de marilyn
manson
accès en fait il fallait un coupable
donc on m'a brandi un peu embêtant c'est
cette effigie du coupage et j'ai décidé
de ne pas répondre à tout cela parce que
je ne voulais pas justement donné les
alimenter cette flamme les gamins
voulait justement acquérir une espèce de
célébrités malsaine la mairie fera à
tenait justement ce qu'il recherchait et
je voulais pas y contribuer donc on
associe le nom marilyn manson à cette
horreur et en fait marine manson est
devenu le produit de colombes a été
ironiquement c'est quand même assez
injuste d'être attaqué par vos
promenades après détection à la cantine
actuelle et il n'a pas traduit vêtements
par actuellement mais en fait tu venais
la finesse
vous dites que cette histoire finalement
permettait d'oublier monica levinsky
parce qu'à l'époque c'était le grand
scandale de monica levinsky on oublie
aussi grâce à ça les bombes balancer sur
le kosovo et vous dites c'est moi qu'on
accuse de provoquer un comportement
violent alors que finalement à la même
époque les états unis bombardé la
yougoslavie
absolue est exactement de scène comme
des seigneurs locaux en dire autant de
ce qui se passe actuellement c'est à
dire qu'on va continuer à censurer les
mots
image ou mais où ma musique
en fait il ya un véritable duplicité du
gouvernement et moi mon rôle c'est
justement de mettre cette démarche défi
il faut que si l'amérique représente la
démocratie moi je leur présentais la
liberté d'expression ce n'est pas
quelqu'un comme moi n'y aurait personne
justement pour remettre en cause les
fausses idées dit à moi qui rôdent kong
et leurs autres justement de remettre en
cause certaines politiques certaines
valeurs ce qui ne veut pas dire que je
déteste
et mon rôle c'est en faire un pays plus
intéressant plus divertissement en étant
beau gosse d'accord
alors le film quand michael moore vous
pose la question et vous dis qu'est ce
que vous diriez au lycée columbine et
vous répondez je les écouterai ce que
personne ne fait rien
fait et c'est quelque chose que je
départ avant l'incident de koloma
n'était pas la première fois qu'une
telle tragédie ne se produise c'est pas
moi qui ai inventé la violence et ce
n'est pas non plus les gamins de
colobane comptes a vanté la violence la
haine du manager à cette tendance une
tradition de s'autodétruire et ça c'est
quelque chose que j'ai toujours évoqué
dans ma musique alors c'est quand même
assez copieux qu'on me montre du doigt
parce que tout ce que je dis tout ce que
je chante c'est un commentaire ce cette
triste réalité et il est vachement sanaa
je trouvais combiné par les nantis
et maintenant
à
voici malgorn
tran soir bonsoir or
voilà un personnage
pas les français maintenant ouais comme
une vache espagnole vaches et cela me
revoilà donc mike horn est ce qu'on
appelle un aventurier de l'extrême c'est
un type extraordinaire la preuve il a
déjà descendu l'amazone à la nage il a
fait le tour du monde en suivant la
ligne de l'équateur est là
et là vous n'êtes faire vingt mille
kilomètres autour du cercle polaire
arctique
c'est la fameuse expédition arctos ce1
alors vous raconter ça dans un bouquin
qui est publié chez x o qui s'appelle
conquérant de l'impossible alors au
départ vous êtes d'origine hollandaise
c'est des hollandais qui sont partis
habiter en en afrique du sud ouest
français on a et on en est au rendez
vous oui pardon comme dave comme
mais je ne peux pas dans le même coin
mais bon on n'est pas trop tôt alors
votre père était directeur de lycée
c'était annexes springbok il est mort
quand vous aviez 15 ans et votre mère
était enseignante à leurs enfants vous
étiez déjà très sportif mike horn et son
avenir de d'aventuriers se dessine assez
tôt à 8 ans vous rejoignez en vélo la
ferme de votre oncle qui est située à
300 km de là 300 kilomètres séparent loi
si tu as du temps
[Rires]
j'ai commencé la drogue tôle
alors quand vous étiez adolescent vous
êtes rentré dans l'armée vous avez été
capitaine des forces spéciales
sud-africaine effet la guerre en namibie
donc ça vous a effectivement formé à la
violence voilà et puis ensuite vous
rentrez dans la vie professionnelle et
la mike horn est employé par son oncle
il fait de l'import export de fruits et
légumes au départ d'ailleurs vous
réaliser une transaction exceptionnelle
sur des choux qui vous a rapporté
énormément d'argent moi j'ai trop vite
trop bien gagner ma vie
mais voilà ça lui plaisait pas parce que
bon il avait plein de blé n'y avait pas
de but dans la vie est là vous
établissez
vous n'avez pas de but dans la vie
ap huit mois
donc là vous êtes a glissé une liste des
endroits de la jungle et des étendues
glacées ou vous aimeriez aller et puis
vous réunissez tous vos amis un jour
ouais quoi j'ai eu tout ce que je
voulais
mais c'était pas ça que je voulais et
puis je disais mais ce soir je fais un
grand feu de chez moi et puis je viens
d'acheter un rat johannesburg un grand
maison il ya une piscine et où je disais
à mes potes écoute via et puis ce soir
je donne tout ce que j'ai à toutes mes
potes et puis on a bu un petit verre et
tout ça ma soeur est avec avocate elle a
pris part préparé tout le contraire je
donnais tout à mes amis et puis je me
retrouvais avec un sac à l'aéroport il a
tout donné alors second vengeance n'est
pas connu
mais s'expose à ce moment là il va
l'aéroport et les seuls pays en fait on
pouvait aller quand on était africain du
sud sans visa c'était israël la suisse
et l'angleterre donc il va l'aéroport à
ce moment là il ya un avion qui part
pour la suisse c'est comme ça que vous
vous retrouvez à zurich exactement
exactement 100 sans rien connaître de la
langue sans rien connaître du pays alors
au début c'était difficile quand même
vous voyez j'ai commencé il y à 360
kilomètres entre zurich et montreux et
puis parce que j'ai parlé du travail
j'ai pas eu l'argent j'ai décidé de
faire ça à pied puis de passer un peu
vers les paysans pour demander s'il y
avait du travail ouais puis c'est
toujours un peu la même réponse
qui
me disait que quoi on n'engage pas des
étrangers 1 et puis là je disais
d'accord et coûteux ouais quoi je
continue d'arriver j'arrivais à montreux
j'ai commencé de volée juste pour rester
vivants vous avez vous évolué des fruits
à wayne a il faut que j'ai dormi dans
des étapes j'ai dormi sous des ponts
enfin c'est incroyable parce que il ya
quelque chose d'extraordinaire cirque en
afrique du sud vous faisiez partie de la
la classe des possédants la classe des
riches des blancs à l'époque c'était
encore la part le ron et puis un jour
vous arrivez en suisse et vous retrouver
dans la position du noir quoi dans la
position du du titre capable efficace
parce qu'ils ont bien regardé ans ouais
mais écoute c'est sûr c'est sûr que si
tu te retrouve dans une situation un peu
que t'as pas vraiment l'habitude du 10
soit tous rentrer à la maison mais parce
que j'ai eu rien à la maison jeudi il
faut que j'ai atteint mes
responsabilités vous aviez comme on dit
brûler vos vaisseaux c'est à dire que
vous n'aviez plus de maison dans
laquelle retournez donc j'étais obligé
de continuer vous faites des petits
boulots vous installez ensuite vous
rencontrer katy qui deviendra votre
votre femme vous commencez à trouver des
sponsors en face et un courage
absolument extraordinaire et là vous
vivez votre première grande aventure en
1997 traversée de l'amérique du sud à
trois il part du perron il fait déjà 600
bornes à travers la cordillère des andes
mais comme ça tu vois sur comment il
fait pour y aller aux tirs ou en avion
ouais j'ai une copain qui était pilote
et puis
non libre où il fait 600 morts dans la
cordillère des andes jusqu'aux sources
de l'amazone et là vous descendez
l'amazone
oui l'idée c'était 6400 km voit les
barrages
l'idée c'était dedans fait traverser
l'amérique du sud mais en solitaire sans
assistance
et puis il des bouées quand il avait un
truc s'appelle l'hydrospeed c'est une
petite planche tu sèmes bodyboard
commandé ces listes comme ça vous aurez
un essai des jambes s'ériger sur les
jambes c'est des lycées c'est déjà fini
deux mondes est élu il ya un animal qui
est pas mal intéressant parce que tu
peux pas vraiment faire pipi dans l'eau
parce qu'il ya
ces deux poissons
de chats mara site dès que tu fais pipi
en fait là you're in salah tirs entre
les sahraouis
brouillard un trou
et
puis en fait tu peux pisser dans vos
mais il faut regarder ton patane en main
c'est ça c'est comme tu fais chier sur
la place rouge ce
qui fait quand même six ans il fait
quand même 6400 km à la nage donc avec
son hydrospeed pour descendre l'amazone
jusqu'à l'embouchure de l'amazone dans
l'océan dans le sens atlantique ses
premières aventures d'isa prix -
deuxième grande aventure qui a encore un
exploit absolument unique le tour du
monde en solitaire par l'équateur son
véhicule à moteur à l'idée c'était de
rester sur l'équateur n'est pas de
m'éloigner plus 40 milles au nord voilà
milles au sud et puis de deux parties du
gabon et quand vous quittez le gabon
c'est la première fois que vous vous
retrouvez seul sur un voilier oui jamais
j'ai jamais c'est la voile en fait c'est
jésus winch est un fait sur du bâti de
laurent bourgnon
pire il part du gabon pour traverser
l'atlantique est la première fois qu ils
essaiment sur un voilier
alors ensuite bon il ya l'amérique du
sud vont traverser l'amérique du sud
l'indonésie avec les révoltes avec le
combat tous avaient un cas
extraordinaire et puis bon voilà vous
êtes élu aventuriers du xxème siècle
quand même ouais pas y avait par un
autre je crois c'est pour ça
bon on a vu donc la descente de
l'amazone à la nage le tour du monde par
l'équateur est là en février 2002 sert
klose donc c'est la dernière expédition
celle que vous racontez dans votre
bouquin conquérant de l'impossible donc
vingt mille kilomètres autour du cercle
polaire arctique
à contre courant et à contrevent alors
on lui dit mais pourquoi quand on fait
vingt mille kilomètres autour du cercle
polaire arctique pourquoi vous le faites
à contre-courant à contrevent qui
s'entend si bien que cinq sa fin
[Applaudissements]
alors quand on lui dit pourquoi vous le
faites à contre courant à contrevent il
dit parce que en cas de réussite dans
l'autre sens j'aurais passé toute ma vie
à me demander comment j'aurai réussi
dans le mauvais sens allez moi je la
mettrais reid a échoué un peu contre
rencontre des aliments que d'aller avec
les ânes un maillot
dit des trucs qui dit les c'est
tellement dur ce qui fait que
trouvent le courage de surmonter toutes
les épreuves et vous dites je les ai
surmonter parce que j'ignorais quelle
souffrance elle représentait si j'avais
su qu'elles souffrent j'allais vivre
j'aurais pas fait vous utilisez des
accessoires aussi à la maison
c'est bizarre qu'on m'écoute pas dit
comment je crois j'ai pas du tout mal il
ya des moments qui est plus dur que les
autres aujourd'hui j'aime c'est mon
métier et puis je fais ça
professionnellement pendant dix ans et
puis c'est moi je vois ça comme tout à
fait normal qu'on fait les courses vous
prenez un caddie ou vous mettez tout
comme sa survie
alors ce qu'il faut savoir quand même
c'est qu'avant de faire le tour du
cercle donc voilà il ya l'envers il ya
eu un voyage préparatoire le voyage
préparatoire il dit bon pour me préparer
à se mettre en forme je vais aller au
pôle nord en solitaire 800 morts
c'est juste pour s'entraîner
juste pour s'entraîner et la grosse
erreur je n'ai pas eu vraiment choix
c'était un moment que je marchais plus
ça veut dire que mon corps génère plus
de chaleur et puis je commence à tomber
dans les permis et puis là c'est la vie
aux ligues lima 1 j'ai enlevé mes move
pour attacher mes chaussures en effet
c'est sur c'est la dernière fois que je
m'enlève mmos tu es là les doigts
explose et alors ce qu'il fait il rentre
dans sa tente il met ses doigts dans le
feu parce qu'ils sont tellement gelés
qui les met dans le feu et est à ce
moment là oui il a eu il a été un peu
amputé oui et à ce moment là et ça sent
la viande brûlée lui sans rien mais ça
s'en va et ça sent la viande brûlée
alors effectivement là vous décidé de
rentrer donc cette expédition
préparatoire n'a pas été mené m décidé
de rentrer pour sauver vos mains en fait
c'est ça exactement et un moment que tu
dises mais là maintenant je dois rentrer
je dois réparer mes mains non autrement
si je continue j'étais à quinze jours du
pôle si je continue je veux permet main
et puis je peux plus rien faire de mal
tout ça parce que tu avais des la
céphalée médiévale
chrome arrive et qu'on marche pas à -50
sap est en fait ça peut être bon sans
compter sur
vous rentrez on vous ampute un peu le
bout des doigts mais vous attendez même
pas le délai normal vous partez pour
cette fameuse expédition donc archos et
là il ya des épreuves absolument inouïe
suis dit ah c'est par exemple un moment
il va en bateau au départ de de norvège
au gua yens landes il ya un trou dans la
coque est là alors là c'est incroyable
cirque d'une main et conduit le bateau
de l'autre ils vident le bateau et les
icebergs qui arrive sur lui les mecs ils
au milieu
céline dion qui
[Applaudissements]
peut pas dormir parce que s'il dort il
peut piloter le bateau peu plus vide et
le bateau donc voila et puis au milieu
des icebergs comme ça créatif dix fois
un peu on n'a pas vraiment les choix du
foie puis 1 si on veut arriver à nantes
il faut serrer c'est vraiment un fou
jouer à chat [ __ ] ou quoi
alors après il traverse le groenland ont
qu'il arrive hollande il a souvent une
longue avec une espèce de de
cerfs-volants quoi et ça va très vite
parce que vous arrivez à faire d un jour
par exemple il fait 18 heures dans la
journée 143 km donc ça va assez vite
vous battez le record de traversée du
groenland grâce à ce système de
cerfs-volants et puis un jour il ya un
vent énorme looping voilà vous êtes vous
et arracher j'étais arraché par une
tempête de vent exactement là c'était
juste moment que tu peut plus gérer la
surface est trop grande de mecar et d'y
vendre sous x 60 70 kilomètres à l'heure
et tu peux plus de sont à voile c'est
sûr qu'il ya un moment que tu vas passer
d'eux une cravate tu vas passer d'un
mode de développement et que le
professeur avait fait là c'est sûr tu tu
tombes il s'en sort à chaque fois c'est
extraordinaire à un moment il arrive
dans une région il doit prendre un
bateau pour aller à calamity belge croit
il doit prendre un bateau et puis bon il
ya la glace qui fait qu'on peut pas
naviguer il fait un détour de 1200 km le
mec avec j'ai pris des tours de 300 m²
sur 2200 km et tout ça à moins 60 dans
la nuit permanente parce qu'en plus de
ça il faut voir ce que c'est ça il fait
même pas jour il neige il fait froid
moins 60 il fait nuit voilà
malheureusement on a trois mois de nuit
ou n'a pas beaucoup de soleil mais on
aurait pu dire des sauvetages 24 24
heures sur 24 et puis là tu peux bien
avancé alors c'est extraordinaire parce
que ce sont des régions où la vie
humaine est impossible si rappeler
celles qui vivent là-bas ce sont les
inuits mais oui bouge pas il reste quoi
ils vivent sur leur graisse comme les
ours quoi ils vivent tout l'hiver sur
leur glace afin qu'on en attendant qu'il
fasse beau et lui non lui il avance là
dedans dans ce pays donc quand même pas
un inuit qui qui fait ce que vous avez
fait quoi c'est parce que les mises au
point compte déjà un ep en plus les in
which has a
au début de l'hiver et puis l'hiver
risque parce qu'il peut plus il voit
rien ouais et puis moi si je restais je
crève et certain que j'ai été obligé
d'un marché en fait de rester vivant et
alors mike votre votre la tente dans
laquelle vous habite elle en quoi les
îles et des zones ils ont à traiter en
fait que ça brûle pas et puis en même
temps les problèmes c'est que tu as tu
as quelque chose à moi 50 que tu peux
pas vraiment plier parce que l'hymne ils
ont au moins 50 en -60 situe le pli 2,3
fois cias à casque en hiver tout vient
vraiment cassant et qu'on a fait alors
et puis là tu dois faire vachement gaffe
quand tu mettes l'attend quand il fait
vraiment trop froid tamer temps pas de
la matraque de m'éclater et puis tu dois
marcher un fait reste pour rester
vivants vous avez quand même envie de
faire pipi de temps en temps écoute
situation avec 700 c'est pas évident
parce que tu ne trouves pas déjà c'est
ça
fait si froid que
ccc 5 litres de l'eau l'eau avant dormir
je bois 5 litres fait ça mais permettent
de réveiller chaque une heure chacune
heure et demie comme ça gèle pas en
dormant et puis je sais que je vais
rêver peut-être autrement tout content
de tout on dort en moi 50 au moins 60 il
ya si tu dors trop profondément un fait
que tu peux jamais tu vas jamais rêvé tu
vas j'allais se dit que la seule façon
de vraiment fier c'est d'avoir envie
pisser et puis la piste et en bouteille
1 et puis parce que la piste est à 36
degrés oui je prends les bouteilles et
puis je chauffe mes pieds parce que mes
pieds à l'extrémité les sacs de couchage
et vu des menteurs
je veux dire un truc quand tu lu le
bouquin ouais je me suis dit c'est vrai
ce que tu dis parce que je me suis
maintenant tout est bidon un moment
c'est tellement énorme ce qu'il a vécu
que tu dis c'est pas là jamais ça jamais
été faire pendant l'hiver et c'est
extraordinaire et alors avais tu chantes
tu te sens pas son intérêt aux attentes
du peuple en disant l'hiver si tu vas
dors tu veux bcta pantalon et puis tu
peux sortait peut-être 10% et puis tu
dois tu veux mais tu sais impossible
d'exposer des petits drapeaux tape au
loin a dit y produire au moins 5 ans
témoin 60 ça veut dire que tout pas son
intérêt relatant y avait une trappe à
l'intérieur attentes je pouvais faire un
petit trou voix quan chi automne en
carrière l'attend mais sans son siège
elle tout de suite quoi ah oui c'est
solide
comme ça tu n'aurais pas des animaux
alors c'est incroyable le pire de tous
et contient un incendie parce qu'à un
moment votre bouteille de benzin tombe
sur le sur le réchaud et alors là en
plein milieu de cette immensité glacée
et ultra froide il ya un incendie et
tout brûle quoi c'est à dire la tante
brûle tout brûler il y a moi j'ai rempli
j'ai mes bouteilles en moi 45 et puis un
jour il y avait la température ça a
chauffé à -22 un épuisant à moi vente il
ya jusqu'à moins 45 il ya 25 degrés de
différence 1 et puis là tu vois un peu
des fils qui a commandité qui s'extrait
ski expansé puis là parce qu'il fait
chaud ils fument prenez-la volume et
puis avec mon réchaud de l'intérieur
l'attend quand j'ai ouvert en fait mon
bouteille ça gicle partout ça gicle un
monsieur moi ça s'écrit sur mon sac de
couchage et en plein feu l'implant plein
milieu de de l'arctique aux sextoys
alors après bon je vais pas tout
raconter mais c'est vraiment génial il
ya l'alaska le détroit de béring la
sibérie il fait tout le tour le mec est
alors parfois vous vous tombez pas ce
que votre corps refuse de vous obéir et
là vous avez la tentation de ne plus
vous relevez la tentation de vous
laisser mourir et si vous entendez la
voix de vos filles
des plus problème c'est que quand quand
on commence déjà les on sait vraiment
pas ce qui se passe avec nous et puis là
c'était après douze heures de marche
voyais un nuage noir qui arrive sur
l'horizon et puis je disais est ce que
j'ai essayé de marcher à travers de ce
top et on essaye de mekla tombe
maintenant et puis j'ai fait une erreur
je disais mais je veux marcher à travers
parce que je peux gagner peut-être cinq
à dix kilomètres et puis là c'est sûr
que la tempête a pas arrêté pour trois
jours et puis avait moment que
physiquement tu es tu étais tellement
fatigué la luge derrière toi pezula cent
cinquante à soixante 160 kg et puis à un
moment que tu peux plus tirer 1 et puis
la conte niveau remonte à 150 km à leur
niveau est venu du nord - je marche vers
l'ouest ça roule en fête foraine ou sur
la glace et puis tu aimes barque avec et
puis là tu dis mais je peux me lève et
je dois encore ramasser un divan je
préfère de mourir parce que comme ça je
n'ai plus besoin de tirer la juge je
n'ai plus besoin de faire quoi que ce
soit je peux que rêver ici il est
vraiment aller au bout le vaincu a
répété écrit en une vie pépère
finalement
oui
deux pays
bravo la saison
pourtant vainqueur soit heureux de vous
avoir
aussi quand vous avez comme la
compassion des marques
tu as lu fait pas lui
j'ai fait trop traîneau dans la vie tu
dis moi j'en tiens t'as pas été très
surpris en fait par la discipline de la
première compagnie parce que tu as été
élevé dans une pension anglaise en
argentine où tu as pris des coups 1
j'ai pas pris des coups il y avait dans
le règlement il y avait ce qu'on appelle
des punitions corporelles à c'était
normal si on a tous vu kif et une palme
d'or à cannes c'est fait vous savez
partie intégrante sauf que le règlement
est très précis quand on fait une
connerie ronces et secouristes ce qui
n'est pas toujours le cas et
règlements tu sais que quand tu rentres
dans le dortoir des filles par exemple
ces vingt coups de canne en tous les cas
c'est dommage que tu es quitté la
première compagnie parce qu'on était
devenue la la mascotte des
téléspectateurs théron fle mentez douche
tout nu c 'est les gens s'étaient
habitués disait l'idole des radiologues
oui oui l'idole des radios la wii 2 et
si ça nous appartient pas moi je ne sais
pas ce qui montre je ne sais pas ce
qu'il fait donc et pourquoi est il
devenu la bête noire des autres
parce qu'ils avaient peur peut-être que
j'aille en finale alors que j'avais pas
fait d'effort physique ouais il te
détester t'as vu en revenant t'as vu les
images tu as vu comment ils te casser du
chapelet la joueuse
j'arrive pas leur en vouloir ouais mais
majorque ont fermé dans un néant un
cercle fermé y penser tous à gagner donc
on gagne ouais et aller alors que c'est
même pas qui tu étais que c'est même pas
que j'avais joué dans un des missions
plus très bien à part dit avoir vu dans
votre émission très loin je ne sais pas
très bien ce qu'elle avait fait dans la
vie non plus cet actif en james bond en
french connection et les regards clés
sous les missions vous allez rural et
vos fiches je n'ai jamais parlé de
métier pendant six semaines
jamais jamais raconter ma vie d'acteur
n'a pas
we might aurait aidé les jours c'est des
gosses [ __ ]
pourquoi tu as fait la première
compagnie
pourquoi j'aurais pas fait c'est un clin
d'oeil à ton fils qui a réussi grâce à
adobe story
je pense que benjamin n'a pas réussi que
grâce aux leçons il est devenu connu
grâce à l'aube story mais disons que ce
qui fait aujourd'hui où ce qu'il a fait
après prouve qu'il avait quand même un
potentiel suffisant pour réussir
dans les weppes benjamin aujourd'hui
c'est mon fils toujours ça n'a pas
changé sa vie
on va faire une interview benjamin
[Musique]
dit papa oui papa pour être jamais de
premier rôle
des gens des îles ont jamais marché
l'anafé des navets un peu pas au cinéma
beaucoup comme beaucoup d'autres hein
c'est comment tu fais dans un james bond
le rôle que j'ai eu c'est très frustrant
ouais surtout connue et va même pas
reconnu il n'a pas vu dans le film j'ai
des moustaches juliette noir un chapeau
si vous n'êtes pas james bond or nur
surtout près dit papa tu aurais aimé
être un héros une fois
j'espère je suis dit tiens
c'est dur d'être acteur papa ah oui
des tracteurs pas star ouais t'as
premiers rôles jusqu'au bout selon une
enquête qui a été fait sur les dix
métiers où on gagne le moins d'argent en
france il ya moins de 750 euros par mois
il ya les intermittents du spectacle
dis papa ça jette un froid je suis
droitier d'ambiance en l'air voilà
et c'est vrai dis papa
c'est pas eu honte de faire la première
compagnie
pas du tout c'est alors là encore moins
que le reste j'assume tout ce que j'ai
fait depuis 35 ans gagner du blé avec ça
pas comme tout le monde
et moi tu t'es vraiment blessé ou tu as
fait ça montre que la pêche la vérité
alors j'écoute flottant de casser une
approche par l'a9 et l'a dit c'est ce
que tu crois que vraiment à kourou le
[ __ ] de kourou ont fait défaut ce sera
dû arrêter le train las vegas on l'a dit
papa oui tu crois que j'ai eu raison
d'écrire mon livre l'an dernier nous un
vrai beau
tu en penses quoi de ma carrière papa de
mon fils très fier et la glace beaucoup
de gens et ça me fait rire tu es fier de
moi oui il est fier de moi
normal à temps s'étant pas mal
je suis pas soult à la tronche de
monfils non j'aimerais bien déjà pas que
ta mère doit tirer c'est là
qu'on n'en parle non mais tu sais dans
le temps avec le temps qui passe j'ai
jamais dis papa thaïlande quand j'ai
fait la story surtout pas
surtout alors là je dis je l'affirmé
haut et fort surtout un tu voulais que
que je fasse quoi quand j'étais petit
papa
je crois que le métier n'a pas passé de
laisser faire son fils ce qu'il a envie
de faire il a fait ce qu'il a eu envie
de faire
dis papa papa oui si la trouves comment
flavie très belle ouais elle te plaît
comme un bon père oui
il ya des trucs que tu m'a jamais dit
papa à lui non à vous peut-être
tu m'aimes
vous où lui et lui oui n'y va pas tu as
peur de mourir
évidemment surtout avec deux côtes
cassées
enfin j'espère que je n'aurai pas
beaucoup on sait pas
regarder
ni papa oui tu as des regrets sur ta
carrière c'est déjà énorme d'avoir de
dire depuis trente ans je vide mon
métier c'est déjà énorme un sans être
que vous dites une star où il peut être
tu as pensé quoi ta vie papa à ma vie
formidable ma vie il le sait formule 1
était comment mamie chiante qui veut pas
savoir
pas mal comme réponse mais elle avait le
pendant de ses défauts y avait beaucoup
de qualités ouais dit papa tu aies
jamais eu envie de lui casser la gueule
à yves montand un montant dont jeu non
même maintenant
[Rires]
non jamais malgré ce qu'il a fait à
maman t'as pas eu envie de lui casser la
gueule non je veux ce qu'il a fait à
maman s'il l'a fait cela regarde maman
et mon ex-femme du rhin où il l'a fait
j'étais pas là
le roi va oui t'as pas un peu grossi
récemment non ça fait dix ans que je
vaux si j'oublie gris selon les rôles
selon quand tu mets green to grow 6 pour
tel ou tel rôle on voit pas tellement la
différence au cedac juste pour un procès
dans lequel philemotte était maigre
fra
jean pierre
mais après tout que c'était ce fonds
prend que je chéris le pape lausanne tu
vas voir
j'habite à
cette fois
à cette once a bien dernière fois c'est
de jouer et jean-pierre la dernière fois
c'est hervé bourges qui à partir des
temps de chats mais je crois qu'il a
touché un ami depuis je crois qu'il est
bon ce n'est plus je sais plus cher
c'est un jeu c'est un jeu et alors il
faut que je fasse quoi tu touches la
[ __ ] d'un mec ça devient de chat voilà
mais il faut le faire discrètement les
arbitres mais tu as une minute un sinon
torres j'avais toute ta vie attention
c'est moi qui ai bien sa vie non non
c'est pas valide et tapas des chapitres
le but ici quand il des chapiteaux en
touchant huit formations
nous
c'est papa jean pierre
pis
une cote
au nom
de carrière sont maintenant ça tire je
mal o
m
c'est shabbat
shabbat shabbat ce genre ait un seul
avec maman
[Musique]
prochain abc alain chabat mais la menace
rôde
[Musique]
ouais c'est guillaume cochin
france
alors guillaume [ __ ] de l'architecte
romancier et vous êtes le mari de perico
chat pas une mince affaire que nous
admirons tous les jours chez laurent
ruquier comment ça se passe ça va assez
plus dur que d'être écrivain a donc eu
ni votre deuxième roman qui s'appelle 10
ans lui connaît pas ce qu'il a fait
ouais voilà
c'est vraiment très mal allô oui oui
soit 10
sepehri [ __ ] monsieur par tous téo
je viens viens pas d'accord je viens si
tu veux je n'ai pas de problème à vie
ainsi sa femme vient péri dommage oui
mais attention
c
ça y est évidemment j'allais jallet fait
de laisser venir au casting tout seul
mais dommage que tu étais là parce qu'il
y avait un truc entre mélanie et
guillaume là je peux repartir si tu veux
c'est ce que je vais vous faire un but
que vous êtes tous les deux une
interview alerte aux roses
terry est ce que tu as besoin d'aimer
pour faire l'amour ou de faire l'amour
pour aimer
moi je dirais les deux ça dépend des
jours elle est honnête tu me diras 1 et
toi moi ça dépend de la fille
c'est quoi ta première pensée péri quand
tu te trouve en face d'un mec séduisant
je me demande si
dit la vérité
la vérité c'est
est ce que je peux lui plairait ce que
ça peut aller plus loin est ce que je
sais pas non franchement je veux tu vois
même séduisant c'est ça chaque fois que
je te vois
tu chantes pas comme des trucs qui te
pousse la
menora marhaba mls
c'est quoi le lieu idéal pour une
étreinte pourquoi ce que les italiens
c'est la machine à laver vous saviez sa
blessure les orages ouais tu resteras
souris sauvages c'est quoi mais pas à
l'intérieur un
trait à guillaume le lieu idéal pour une
étreinte pour toi juste au pied du lit 1
avant de monter avant d'envoyer ce qui
m'est chère
à d'autres questions
guillaume est ce que tu préfères une
femme qui pèse bien mais qui est
infidèle ou une femme qui baisent mal
mais qu'est fidèles femme qui laisse
bien fidèle arrêts oui est ce que tu
préfères draguer de faire draguer
ça dépend qui gère face de moi
mais j'aime bien me faire draguer tu
devras avec des fois
ouais nuit je les draguer qui tu
préfèrerais qu'elles te quitte pour une
femme pour un homme pour un objet
simplement ah ouais moi aussi je peux
faire est quitte pour un homme oui c'est
vrai est ce que tu préfères être caressé
par quelqu'un qui te répudie ou battu
par quelqu'un qui t'aiment battu par
quelqu'un qui m'aime
est ce que tu préfères que perry couche
avec un autre en pensant à toi ou couche
avec toi on pense en un autre quelle
couche avec moi en pensant un autre moi
c'est pas mal ça qu'elle couche avec toi
oui ah oui même si jamais sa raison sa
carrière multirisques et la malle
ouais et toi je préfère me coucher avec
toi en pensant à une autre petite couche
avec une autre pensons à toi
qui couche avec moi en pensant à moi ah
c'est pas possible c'est trop tard
est ce que bon ça fait 20 ans que cet
ensemble est ce que c'est encore un
fantasmes inavouables et non réalisés
inavoués non ils ont étouffé on s'est
tous dit surtout
est ce que l'amour est compatible avec
le mariage perry a péri de pendre à oui
on
assiste ici complètement la presse la
preuve la preuve vivante depuis 20 ans
je les adore et j'espère que c'est
les mariés de la 2 depuis 20 ans vous
êtes pas trompés jamais
trompé n'ont trompé non parce que
celui-ci s'est trompé ça dépend ce que
tu sais sa réponse que tu suces perry
est ce que sucer c'est tromper
si tu mens oui
pour moi tromper c'est mentir
tu entends bien oui c'est vrai
nom s'est tu ne ment pas t'as pas trompé
donc voilà après donc sucer s'est pas
trompé son homélie donc tu vas bosser
jaloux et j'ai quitté le club
tu penses quand on avoue finalement
non pas quand on avoue quand on dit
ouais c'est pas à vous et à vous et ce à
des fellations avoué à demi du co2 mais
oui non mais avouez c'est à dire que tu
as menti et que tu te leurs proches et
qu'ensuite tu te dis tiens je vais
l'avouer je vais le dire là c'est pas du
tout ça
donc simuler ses troupes et ouais
bah oui je suis arrivé s'est trompé
on apprend des trucs
c'est le service public annoncés plus
obligés d'apprendre des choses un petit
peu de gens est-ce que vous éteignez ou
allumer la lumière quand vous baisez
chez vous non franchement non il n'y a
pas de règle je ne suis pas t'attendre
est que toi tu non non j'ai la drague
libye depuis 82
n'ont pas de règles c'est quoi la zone
la plus érogène chez toi perry pas une
jatte
merci il a dit pour moi
kerry avec quelles personnes ici
présentes tu aimerais avoir une aventure
soit honnête
imagine conçoit dans un monde idéal où
ça pose pas de problème on a connu ça
dans les années 70 mais bon maintenant
c'est fini un truc à plusieurs
mais pas en dessous moi parce qu'il fait
130 kg
alors on y va c'est guillaume et honnête
avec qui tu voudrais avoir une aventure
là à moi même avec ma voisine il est
génial
ça c'est de la merde
il
te la nef attache pas miss france
est ce que tu préfères une femme belle
école ou une femme moche et intelligente
mal vous l'avez l'école
[Applaudissements]
est ce que tu préfères une femme
comprend sans la comprendre qu'on
comprend sans la prendre on comprend
sans la prendre ah ouais ouais j'ai pas
compris des capable de ça toi qu'on
comprend sans la prendre je préfère une
femme qu'on comprend et comprend pas si
je pouvais posséder que la moitié de
perry tu prendrais le bas ou le haut ou
le bas le bas
pourquoi là bas parce que y'a
et tu vois si vous répondre que la
moitié de guillaume tu pourrais le bas
ou le haut non moi je prends le haut
parce que tout est dans la tête
de tous les journaux mais si justement à
tout est dans la tête parce que même si
on reparlait de fantasmes sexualité et
c'est assez aussi dans la tête parce que
quand j'en viens du coteau bout du
compte ce on s'est rencontrés par le
haut par le haut voilà merci merci
dernière question vous baiser avant le
restaurant où après le restaurant au
restaurant tableau
ça peut être au restaurant oui plus
souvent après paiement plus souvent
après qu'avant chaque fois que ces deux
restaurants à bon escient tous les soirs
[Musique]
attention
watts
alors qu'arte autoflagellation vous
devez à j'adore oh oui vous fouetter en
nous confiant la plus grande faute de
votre carrière est ce qu'on a le
martinet et méline ah oui à le fouet à
s'étendre dans la gueule alain
allez vas-y guillot frappe
ça passait par
là
pierre
jean pierre
guillaume leblut jean pierre tu veux
voir ce que dans le fouillis vous il
faut le foie l'envoyer derrière
faut faire claquer
et jean-pierre insultant en allemand va
tomber cette
affaire
jean pierre carré sport en même temps
pays envoûtant possible
écoute on veut passer à celui là m'a
aussi gros que c'est
horrible tu préfères juste être fouettée
sans avouer le péché je crois oui
j'accueille maintenant lui simon
liberati
lmh a même chose pour moi
oui
ouais
mr
bah ça va aller icra clown et a répondu
ah oui elle était parfaite
ces couches cette bâtisse a fait d'eux
des plus beaux endroits alors simon
liberati votre premier roman anthologie
des apparitions chez flammarion fait
beaucoup parler je dirais même que tout
le monde en parle c'est le cas de le
dire voilà alors le pitch je vais le
faire qu'est ce que vous en pensez
une
c'est
alors le pitch était éteinte et son
éditeur toi mais une telle admiration
pour simon que je m'arrête louche je
n'en avais exprimé je peux je peux pas
m'exprimer sans pleurer sur son livre je
me sers un très beau livre bien sûr je
fais le pitch d'accord alors c'est
l'histoire de claude et de sa soeur
marina durant la dolce vita des années
70 le palace le studio 54 saint tropez
ibisa voilà et aujourd'hui quand le
livre commence claude touche le rmi et
marina a disparu voilà c'est le pitch il
passe son temps à se demander où elle
est et il passe son temps à se remémorer
la bonne époque voilà donc c'est
l'histoire de claude de marina et puis
elle est riche et puis à la drogue et
puis à la frime et tout ça fait une
espèce de
social grâce sur la grâce et sur cette
gloire que certaines personnes on a
l'âge de 15-16 ans et qu'elle ne
retrouve jamais ses pouces tiens sauf
que c'était des gens qui avaient pas
vraiment le sens des réalités dont qu'il
comprenait pas très bien comment ça
pouvait fonctionner et il y avait il y
avait des tas de gens qui tournait
autour d'eux comme des espèces de comme
des papillons autour de la lampe
vraiment finalement ils se sont fait
bouffer alors que la lampe en général
elle bouffe les papillons sont fait
bouffer par les papillons quoi voilà
alors on pense évidemment à écrite caven
de jean-jacques show de suite moi toi
non mais si je
danse est très forte pourquoi vous avez
édité ce bouquin frédéric dans l'argent
déjà non c
éditeur c'est un métier très pénible on
lit beaucoup de choses
pas terrible et et quand j'ai lu le le
texte de liberati je me suis dit ce
métier est une chance ce métier est un
honneur voilà c'est tout ce que j'ai à
dire je
sais que c'est tout ce que vous aurez vu
toute la critique littéraire la saluer
il n'y a pas un journaliste qui n'est
pas été inspiré ça veut dire que des
types qui d'habitude écrivent peut-être
pas des articles passionnants se met à
écrire mieux en ayant lu son livre le
talent et les comptages et en ce qui le
concerne voilà bon moi je dis je sais
pas je trouve que c'est c'est
fantastique que vous l'ayez invités il
est très tard
non mais c'est important aussi parce que
c'est bon je juloux et je pense que
peut-être dans dans quelques décennies
on continuera de lire son livre et nous
tous on sera oublié
vous avez d'autres
quels conseils vous lui donneriez
frédéric à simon liberati
de continuer à vivre
c'est gentil ça oui parce que c'est pas
c'est pas toujours c'est pas toujours ce
qui ressort c'est face est très charmant
j'ai eu beaucoup de textes magnifiques
etc mais j'avais l'impression que
c'était un peu d éloge funèbre est bon
c'est vrai que mon livre étant assez
négatif et donnant une image assez assez
positive la destruction on pouvait
penser que bon voilà pourquoi il est
pourquoi il est là à essayer de vendre
ce bazar qui après tout n'est qu'un
appel à se jeter par la fenêtre quand
même malgré tout quand on le lit et et
hebron basse et c'est un peu là je crois
je crois que c'était là il y avait une
certaine forme de d'esprit
c'est à cette époque est constitué à
penser que bon il fallait il fallait y
aller à fond et voilà quoi donc c'est le
livre un peu qui rend hommage à un
certain nombre de gens qui sont plus là
forcément et un certain qu'un disparu à
certains qui sont encore là mais qui
sont plus vraiment vraiment aussi jolie
qu'ils étaient à l'époque et et voilà
c'est une sorte de face et pas un
hommage funèbre mais
ccc différentes de lyrisme un peu un peu
à peu nostalgique mais pas
voilà je sais je sais pas plus je rends
hommage à un certain nombre de personnes
qui sont plus là quoi et maintenant on
passe au musée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
qui va limiter d'avoir pour commencer le
mec qui présente son émission de
télévision pour la première fois à bon
et bien bon soir mais aussi un musée
mais dieu a pardon mesdames et messieurs
aux jo aujourd'hui si et je suis très
content de ce temps où est la caméra eh
bien oui alors je
moi je trouve qu'il le fait mieux que
moi
alors tu les a appelés lucien comme ton
vrai prénom oui je vais plus réussi à
aller tu l'a appelée du sien tu veux
qu'ils soient peintres ou écrivains
géant et qui fera ses voisins
comme toi et je lui a préféré au tu
voudrais qu'il qui peignent ou qu'ils
écrivent ou qu'il fasse de la musique
faut qu'ils fassent les trois sets archi
architectes by on va se marrer ce gamin
maintenant mais je n'aime pas ça et pas
les footeux obligera pas si votre
expert-comptable par exemple à l'oreille
il y aura beaucoup de points
avec tout ce que tu t'en vois tu avais
pas peur qu'il soit un peu mongolo lulu
non
il fougères
voyez pas peur il est mis en couverture
imagine pas piper non mais tout ça
c'était pas c'était pas des yeux de
panthou oui ma bouche pipe ouais de son
père ou de sa mère
c'est fini tu vas encore faire beaucoup
d'enfants comme ça
c'est le dernier par décret et alors
imagine que tu repars à zéro là tu
remets les compteurs à zéro tata 0 ans
comme lui et puis tu préférais quoi
avoir le goncourt ou être numéro 1 au
top 50
c'est le goncourt kodak est dans le top
50 avec ces mecs bien c'est ce que tu
veux dire
si tu apprenais que charlotte se shooter
un jour cette soirée quoi et là je me
tue tu te tue
je prends une overdose de
de pernod alors deux choses 1
je suis pas prêt pass inadmissible
il admissible voilà je sais rien ballon
tu écoute tous sérieux une admission je
me suis elle me tuer c'est elle qui me
tue et qui me tue est parfait et à poser
mais charlotte ne sut je suis très
jamais serge nous tiens combien pour le
titre de vsd 5 pourquoi parce que j'aime
pas du tout le terme beurre avant comme
ça qu'elle n'avait pas encore exactement
comme paris je dis toujours mais je suis
un arabe français mais je suis pas peur
donc 5,5 et gérone voix passe quand on
n'aime pas ces généreux de mettre la
moyenne oui c'est sûr et combien pour
plusieurs sera à 5
pourquoi
parce que c'est la campagne anti drogues
il ya un côté qui m'agace un petit peu
dans son aspect terroriste je veux dire
la drogue c'est l'alcool et tout ça
c'est aussi c'est aussi du plaisir et ça
on le dit pas il faudrait quand même que
les gens et tous les éléments en main et
pour être à même de juger après alors
c'est vrai que la drogue c'est de la
merde mais c'est de la merde à longue
échéance et je trouve que c'est bien que
les gens sachent exactement mon tibia
non parce que la drogue c'est la mort 1
c'est pas longue échéance qu on tabac
moins cher langues et sciences puisque
j'ai bientôt 58 ans la garde robe cette
mort
échéances immédiates
à la tête en sang il ya des grandes
royer qui se portent comme des charmes
enfin bon je défends pas la drogue mais
je veux dire que j'estime que les gens
doit avoir tous les éléments en main
être à même de juger eux vous allez les
petits grains qui dit qu'ils n'y
connaissent rien 1 et or en injectant
dans le coca cola et dans l'est dans les
lycées non mais ça c'est dans la presse
à sensation non c'est la vérité
[Applaudissements]
moi je veux pas je me plaquer charlotte
je suis je ne veux pas que charles choot
je dis pas que lui ce shoot
hier très fournie on verra ça tout à
l'heure est ce que ça te laisse le temps
de s'occuper un peu des dames quand même
ben oui ça c'est un truc par contre dont
je m'occupe le plus possible le plus
possible alors j'ai lu dans une
interview que des fois sur scène ça dure
est tellement longtemps tu étais
tellement bien que tu avais des
éjaculations sur scène c'est vrai ça ou
c'est la journaliste qui avait inventé
ça on ça m'est arrivé mais ça m'est
arrivé mais j'étais vraiment bien c'est
par là bas il faut croire j'espère ça va
t'arriver aujourd'hui en tous les cas
berne a stick le plus mastoc
faire le plus pervers
c'est l'avion
on y va les yvon dans la robe 'l'indice
l'adresse de la plante dit simon un
hôtel de la rive gauche
voilà
ça va feignasses du foot
quand on part et les [ __ ] allons-y
étendant simon simon ça vient d'où ça ça
vient de l'est de la france et du peu
plus aussi docile dire quoi ça mad men
et et gisèle mon père était à promat
joyeux marianne
on
t'en fais pas pour lui
mais toi genou réseau revue avec
qu'est-ce que tu alors maintenant on te
demande d'esker à thiennes vous savez
manier l'a déjà eu des rapports
homosexuels
n'ont jamais eu ni avec le pen fn à
savoir écouter un peu hâlé convient de
mettre ta bébé avant toi mais au fait
combien de fois on ne dit rien et vise à
inviter votre charmante et
le pen marché qu'elles fassent ils se
battent et choisissent alors je ne dis
rien non je dis rien j'ai produit tout
le monde tu as peur d'un contrôle fiscal
seulement j'ai profité de ce week-end
t'as pas envie de répondre on va gens du
cachemire indien a fait bien
mieux là hein
c'est ça ben alors la politique tu vas
voter pour fillon 86 rien il va voter
pour qui il va voter pour qui désire
tout vous dire on verra ça plus tard il
va devenir une fois pour la tique est
alors je
crois des films toute ta vie
seniors à la floride comme sa soixante
dix ans tu continueras tu penses à web
et chacun 70 à jour maximum d'argent
j'ai du mal bref obligé d'être flic non
plus obligé pour la main sur la gueule
on y étaient beaux yeux là c'est à dire
pas mal de propositions de paix des non
mais arrête arrêtez avec vos questions
marre et j'ai eu envie de rien envie de
répondre
je vais te montrer moi
tu vas répondre ouais
ouais
et quand tu bosses tu éteins la lumière
pas toujours pas toujours tube assisté
sur la table de la cuisine ou dans les
salles de may a pas de règle là non plus
il n'ya pas de rallonger rebond tube est
pathétique ont leurs règles
tous les ans une fille cassé règle
voudrait vraiment envie de séduire jack
magnifique à ces règles ça faisait ça va
passer vraiment à la télé ça va vraiment
la fin leur explique tout ce que ça fait
de mettre des capotes
est ce que fait plaisir ça fait mal mais
ça réduit plaisir ça ait du plaisir sarr
et du plaisir qu'ils préfèrent attraper
le sida que mettait capote c'est ça non
il serait ce qu'une seule solution mon
patin le sida c'est nous mais dès
qu'elle en est dans la merde
non quand même fait saigner je réclame
un gros plan sur le doit absolument fait
saigner la série
d'interviews il serait tellement immonde
sa maman tellement triste de vous voir
là dedans à ça la police locale et le
talent est bien logique les bandits le
cas servi de faire quoi quand on était
petits on voulait sauter karen cheryl
on l'a vu à l'appui envie de
dire si vous tentez derrière linéaire
voit plein de boutons sous la peau le
maquillage suis interpellé c'est alors
c'est quoi ça ces associations c'est le
foie sa main ça c'est parce que chaîne
j'allais vous rencontrer david pollet ou
quoi c'est possible je puis craque mais
tu as toujours ses chroniques ses
boutons du doigt toujours ça non ma main
ça m'arrive juste on
c'est un stress ça stresse tu vois c'est
monté entre axa fait ça
pour le stress monte sur tu as fait tu
veux vraiment savoir oui c'est quand je
vais avoir mes règles
générales
appelées comment il s'appelle mario il
s'appelle comment alberto comment tu
sais maintenant allez donc comment tu ne
sais qu'ils appellent alberto
s'appelle comment
il s'appelle alberto il fait quoi il
travaille dans la mode justice non non
il ya des magasins
gb déjà
écoute jusqu'à présent ça va donc ils
s'en sortent bien fait des deux les
[ __ ] déroule avec moi il ne fait qu'une
seule chose il est hétéro et puis s'il
fait perdre des points derrière c'est
pas grave je vais bénabar des
édiles ont été plutôt le sentiment
d'être clitoridienne ou vaginale comme
une fille je pense souple et tous les
deux tous les deux ouais ça dépend tu
pensais je dire cote tata va pas d'un
côté mieux vaut essayer donc tout à fait
de l'autre et à mal aussi et non on
touche par réflexe
ah ah
attention didier
aux platines j'accueille l'homme qui a
peiné graf qui a fait tous les graves
qu'elles en studio ramzy montre
voilà ramzy qui a fait une sélection
dont flers aidé à vous connaissez le
principe donc je veux l'interprète un
donc au départ il ya deux équipes il ya
l'équipe de grèce jones contre l'équipe
de chirel et puis après il y aura la
série des banques qu avec chacun pour sa
gueule tout le monde connaît l'histoire
tu es prêt ramzy chiot peine de renvoi
le premier morceau je veux l'interprète
attention la der prête attention
ramzy
je sois
qui a dit cindy lauper
[Applaudissements]
l'indian resort
je vois la connais je crois qu'on a
besoin d'un petit replay
mais attention radi
cki exotiques aux exo jean luc reichmann
jean loubat un peu le goût de la vie en
même temps
mais bin ça fait un point partout voilà
on commencerait proprement avec un point
partout c'est quoi la et maintenant je
dis ramzy deuxième morceau attention
très
solide
il a dit
je connais dans la rade à la 20e'
sylvain si je crois que c'est un nouvel
point les 8° john a
oui
ces quelques tout est là ce classement
romand
[Applaudissements]
à
ça fait un poids pour l'équipe de
graisse jaune puisque c'est quelqu'un de
ce côté là qui répondu simplement public
ja je veux signaler taihei public qui
jonathan non je veux signaler aux
poulamons adam se signaler au public toi
on avait souligné que si vous répondez
avant les invités le point va à l'autre
équipe qui si les invités ne trouve pas
et vous répondez le point va à cette
équipe d'accord ok c'est que la belle a
le public a répondu de son côté menacé
d'une grève jones qui marque un point si
l'équipe du brésil
attention djamel concentre-toi cinq
hommes disent un robot en même temps je
n'ai jamais entendu cette chanson
c'est pas un rebeu et c'est un remix
attention donc maintenant non non je lui
dis que c'est un rebeu c'est mustapha
dance ouais car au mixer les clashs mois
voilà les cinq ans car au mr ouai bon
voici là aussi attention vous êtes prêts
à bombarder un
jamais à
j'ai choisi
on est à 2 partout attention c'est très
bagarrer comme comme conteste ce soir on
passe au numéro 4 a dit s'il vous plaît
s'il vous plaît
il ya une erreur bras alors il a dit il
a dit le nom du titre quel est le groupe
qui interprète ce morceau
[Musique]
jeu blanc du groupe la vie
taisez vous oui personne ici personne le
public
bonjour à vos marques
rennes caen
c
[Applaudissements]
ça fait deux points pour l'équipe un peu
cher n 3 points pour l'équipe de gaza
c'est ça vous voulez faire au début je
voulais pas faire le malin ok
aujourd'hui granby granby il ya un truc
que je te propose ouais parce que là je
vois que l'ambiance commence à chauffer
mais moi j'ai mes potes qui sont l'avant
j'aimerais bien qu'il vienne bas qui
viennent hé les gars
bien tu de la cité qui va arriver on
voulait sortir le quartier musique
alors s'il vous plaît les amis vous vous
répartissez voilà quoi bon jouer joue
pas tes potes maintenant à y joue pas
assez sur hanoi connaissent
jamais je te rappelle le pays doit qui
fait ça va danser dans le sine qua
non enseignant comment alors allons-y
maintenant on passe au numéro 5
attention
on souffle pas les mecs sains attention
à petit comme julie la platine ne marche
pas avec tes conneries je t'ai je sais
de qui la plainte qui ne marche pas
c'est qu'elle compte je sais pas qui tu
es mort d'olivier
tendue maigrir
ça marche pas
[Musique]
ouais
et
[Musique]
ils sont bien ses pattes ramzy ils sont
très bien un gars du musée c'est les
plus forts ouais faut pas chercher ses
glorieux et stéphane et miami s'en
méfier alors
attention face au numéro 6 n'empêche que
l'étranglement
ouais
quand jane elle n'a jamais lu que les
réponses du bois mais arrêtez marvin
gaye savoir si toute mon enfance
c'était banking systems are being et non
non c'est quoi colette renard
[Musique]
bienvenue sont de la chine mort il ya
une heure acheter j'ai fait la
rénovation pied à pied mais sa machine
journée non mais ça c'est parce que tu
as triché je savais avant d'être
arrêtées dans tout de suite samedi les
embrouilles là bas nous fait une
embrouille de façon non
jamais jamais c'est leur brûle
avec la boulaye cette année même si on
est
débordé
c'est comme m'a dit je veux dire n'est
pas ma victoire à trois points l'équipe
devient sinueux j'ai triché c'est ça
notre maman
m
j'ai continué
fallait repartir sur sa non j'aurais
jamais dû faire un blind test des robots
je suis perdu je suis perdu bon bah
c'est pas peur toujours cérisola n'ont
jamais parlé de ma vie libre mais là ok
alors j'attends maintenant ça va melvin
mais quatre partout laisse tomber tu
mets ce cas là partout
bon calcul
nos juniors bon vous êtes antisémites
antisémite tu perds ton sang-froid trust
voulons bien attention à ce que je sois
parti m'attendais pas au stop ça ce que
je propose c'est que là on en est à 4 4
et où tutu mais tu mets la chanson
numéro 7 et 30 jeu normalement s'il vous
plaît qu'est ce que c'est un solide à la
série dallas êtes-vous tulle en revanche
normalement par trois irakiens la
chanson numéro sept
chansons 2009 très bien et ce matin bien
vu etienne c'est une bonne recrue vas-y
g 10
[Musique]
jean
m
[Applaudissements]
alors
à pala
[Musique]
ouais
pareil
[Musique]
bon tout les cas je sais pas qui gagne
mais moi je me régale
bonheur on continue en asie continue
[Musique]
yahoo
au queen's no
wave comme on dit d'elle rajhi
[Musique]
et
je pense pas non comment tu t'appelles
comment penser qu'à souffler
comment tu t'appelles comme fusion mary
2 shirel il s'appelle
alors mazel tov bon moi je lève images
et bien je vais pas les mêmes sans
tarder mais peu importe en même temps
c'est c'est de la musique c'est de la
bonne musique ça commençait pas comme
com com com non non non ils échangent
les assembler
pour un
bon alors ouais d'original d'accord bon
désolé non en tunisie
[Applaudissements]
quel drame du g 10 dinars frenzy dis moi
ce que tu veux mais en face parce que
c'est pas les mêmes titres que je viens
c'est la fuite ah ouais bah ce que
continue la suite ok bon basique pour
les tranquille pépère mais l'histoire
s'est pas devenu séductrice à coeur
l'asie est génial
alors la conversion de cette chanson je
voudrais que tu fasses quelques pas de
danse sur scène sur cette musique parce
que je t'ai vu dans ses notes aux
spéciales par des gens non il est énorme
quand il danse là dessus attention jose
comme les commerces irobo pacifique en
voilà on s'en fout du blind pleinement
son rôle du blind l'os attention c'est à
nous de vous
[Applaudissements]
non non
[Musique]
jamel debbouze bon mon corps gras comme
si non alors je vais te dire on va
passer directement au bon qu aux bons qu
on passe au banco abbas au bon coup du
sort on va pas y arriver donc mais vis
tu effaces son ardoise mikit blanka oui
c'est bien c'est bien assez bien c'est
bien connu le plein confiance aux bongos
on passe au bond soudain 18ème l'andorre
life une équipe et
c'est chacun pour sa gueule branco
tu prennes on n'a pas voulu faire un
plan qu'ils
ne restent pas bons coups ç'a rhin marc
jaming
jamais p mais enfin c est une api du
mont bouquet ample alors encore en moi
je connais le gars ben sinon vous aurez
nikhil blanket alors le banco vous
connaissiez me dis qu'il faut refaire
l'amiral de gaulle
thierry
emprunt l'a12 n'en restons baissiers
mois les banques conan je te jure ce
journal est tombé chez moi les bons
coups là vous avez unique et le bts
c'est pas moi c'est là mais je sais mais
bon qui donne des frais temmar alors le
replay du dernier n'a fait mal et banco
et et les bons coups vous connaissez le
principe c'est chacun pour sa gueule
donc là il ya pas de relation n'y a pas
de discussion possible donc pour toi
c'est la 14 mois
attention je veux l'interprète ya plus
d'équipés ya plus d qui place et chacun
pour soi ça va aussi ramzy vas-y vas-y
vas-y way sur way certains ouais on est
parti ouais djamel tu triches bah ouais
ouais ouais
à
non ouais
non ma fille tu as réussi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
donc et a marqué qu'à marquer dans ma
fille ok on continue
avec moi ah bon
mexico jusqu'à 19 l'année dernière la
première seconde c'est que directement
2011 aura le
bon attention super banco c'est vrai que
c'est pas possible de faire un laisse
tomber on se l'est rendu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'hérault cela
[Musique]
oui
mais qui chante ça c'est pas un peuple
devenu homme qui chante
faux nom tagro remballe là non las des
scandales à
13 mars oui j'ai gagné un super boulot
l'adapah je suis venu j'ai gagné sur un
beau coup je crois qu'une deuxième fois
que je gagne un autre enfant c'est lui
qui m'a dit ah bon maintenant le méga
bon qu'on rencontre fut mais restons
mergault
[Musique]
lemay gabon co
acadia
[Musique]
quoi
non non non non qui chante ça je garde
un
goût amer je vous ai donné l'âge aussi
relativement gatti qui chante attendait
encore à la brigade sud major yapluka
veux tu le dis pas il n'y a plus qu'un
truc c'est
du très bon coup très bienvenu travaux
qu un message de l'huissier du jeu qui
vient de démissionner j'aime lettres
journal de m une chaudière à
démissionner
attention est celui qui trouve j'ai fait
une visite guidée des jeunes
tuent connexes à celui riche en messages
que les pires à 18 ans
[Musique]
boutin
bravo kwakwa
18 cents enfin il fallait
c'est vraiment très fort qu'il chantait
cgd france 69 ans comment tu peux
connaître sympa françois fellmann
l'encyclopédie de la fin que c'est moi
j'étais trop vieux je crois que tout le
monde aura compris que tu manques à
gagner tu n'en as perdu c'est un peu
comme l'école dé phrase de jacques
martin voilà merci à mme ghita pianic
taviani qui était alors la salle jamais
de toute l'histoire du bilan est
de tous les plans tu avais tu as raison
c'est le plus gros malaise qu'on ait
jamais vu
complètement 10,3 y est maîtresse anne à
saint clar africaine malgré tout le
quartier elle signifie rien dit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les
marques
[Musique]
bon bah
ciel
gucci marque phare
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu